google is one of the world's leading
software and technology developers every
year google introduces new technical
discoveries and advancements that are
amazing and beneficial to people all
around the world
because more individuals are using cloud
the google cloud platform has
experienced an increase in utilization
in recent years
a variety of google cloud services for
global consumers
have been introduced in response to the
high demand of computing resources
someone realizing the popularity and the
need for learning about computing
resources of gcp
i have brought a new video of simply
learn on google cloud in-depth tutorial
2022
in this video i'll take you through
crucial gcp services and their in-depth
concepts
so without doing any further ado let's
get started
but before diving deep into the concepts
we will first cover the basics starting
with understanding what is gcp followed
by the gcp tutorial in which we will
explore gcp services
and its infrastructure
then we will have a quick comparison
between gcp aws and azure along with
hands-on experience with gcp
then we will move on to gcp web hosting
and then we will understand google
machine learning with proper
demonstration and at last
we will look into the essentials of
google cloud platform fundamentals
and how to exactly prepare for it
by the end of this video i can assure
you that all your gcp related concepts
would have been clear
so for this training with me i have a
experienced gcp specialist together
we'll walk you through the different
crucial gcp keynotes
so let's start with an exciting video on
google cloud in-depth tutorial
2022 before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell icon and never miss an update
from simply done
good morning and good evening everyone
so welcome to this session on google
cloud platform my name is aj and i'm an
instructor with simply learn and also
working as a big data and cloud
architect for various clients across
globe in this session we learn about
google cloud platform wherein we will
learn about what is cloud computing why
google cloud platform what is gcp that
is google cloud platform
google cloud platform domains
about a use case that is federal use
case and also a quick demo on using
services from google cloud platform so
when we talk about google cloud platform
we also need to know what is cloud
computing so cloud computing is the use
of hardware and software components to
deliver a service to a network
users can access these files and
applications
and services provided by a cloud
provider
from any device that has access to
internet
in short cloud computing is a way where
cloud provider provides
access to different services such as
resources and when we talk about
resources here we talk about computing
we talk about memory we talk about
processing power we talk about storage
and we also talk about different
services which cloud providers make
available for the users now that
allows us for automatic software
integration
backup and restoring data unlimited
storage capacity having a reliable use
of different services and
having a cost efficient solution
now we know that cloud computing's
models there are different service
models so you have platform as a service
you have infrastructure as a service and
you have software as a service and these
are the prominent models which are
offered by different cloud providers
such as google cloud
such as google you have amazon you have
azure and also some organizations build
their own private clouds using open
source openstack
let's focus more on google cloud
platform and what it has to offer and
how it is gaining popularity in the
market with different organizations
which would want to work on a cloud
platform or which would want to work
on
an infrastructure
which is modernized so when we talk
about cloud computing this is one of the
approach which organizations can take to
instantaneously benefit from
modernization using different services
different platforms and also newer
technologies
for their various requirements such as
scalability or dynamic businesses
before we get into google cloud platform
it is also
good to understand where you can find
some useful resources about google cloud
platform and here you have a website
which is
from your google cloud so this is
cloudacademy.com
library slash google
and here you can create a free account
now that would give you just seven days
trial but that has a lot of
videos which talk about your google
cloud platform and essentials and it has
various certification related videos
which you can access and then after
seven days after you have tried you can
obviously go for a paid account where
you can take detailed learning from here
now this is your training library which
shows your different cloud providers
such as amazon microsoft seo
gcp and then you have various other
topics which are specifics to
organization
you can obviously look at the pricing
and you can also look at resources which
will give you a good
experience in learning from these videos
you can also create a free account which
i will walk you through later so you can
create a free account on
cloud.google.com now when i say free
account that basically means it allows
you to create an account and every user
who creates an account gets a 300 free
credit which can be used to practice
brush up your skills and also explore
and learn about different
google cloud products which are offered
by google
now coming back to our google cloud
platform let's understand why google
cloud platform so google cloud platform
is popular for many reasons now let us
see a few of most important reasons why
it stands out when you talk about
pricing pricing is one of the
significant factors that make google
cloud stand out among the other cloud
providers
it offers a monthly pricing plan which
is built according to monthly usage and
when we talk about billing here the
billing can be in hours it can be in
minutes and it can also be in seconds
there are different options when you
talk about your pricing which can be
found from your google cloud web page
now pricing could be
based on preemptive machines pricing
could be based on reserved instances or
reserved resources i'll show you the
link where you can find more details on
pricing part of it
so
google cloud really has
various pricing options which help
customers in their different
requirements whether they would go for
any of the service models such as
infrastructure as a service platform as
a service or even software as a service
one more attractive thing about google
cloud pricing is that it provides
committed use discounts for example
under this scheme you can purchase a
specific amount of virtual cpu cores and
memory for up to 57 percent discount of
regular prices if you commit usage for
either one or three years now this is
just one option there are various such
options which you can learn about from
the google cloud's page
and that really suits
different customers for their different
requirements
now when we talk about speed we don't
need to really challenge this aspect
when it comes to google services so
google provides its google cloud and
google app customer speed up to 10
terabytes because of its faster cable
system there are different kind of
machines which can be used if you are
talking about computation if you are
talking about memory hungry applications
or even storage intensive workloads
all in all
speed is one of the defining
characteristics of google cloud services
the cable has connections over u.s west
coast
main cities in japan and even major hubs
in asia this speed enhances performances
and leads to customer satisfaction now
when we talk about customers any or
every customer would prefer to have low
latency
high throughput based services they
would want to use higher speeds to
process their data in as less time as
possible google provides a low latency
network infrastructure in fact you can
say that when you are using google cloud
services you are using the services from
the same infrastructure which google
uses for its popular services such as
google search or even youtube which is
one of the second largest repository
which can be accessed for videos now
when we talk about big data big data is
data which is
very complex has lot of other
characteristics such as
your volume
you have velocity you have variety you
have veracity validity volatility
virality and so on so if an organization
has is working on big data google cloud
can be a better choice because google
has many innovative tools for cloud
warehousing for example such as bigquery
and even real-time data processing tools
such as data flow bigquery is a data
warehouse that allows massive processing
of data at high speeds
basically working on your structured
data google also has launched some new
machine learning from artificial
intelligence tools now there are various
other services which we can which we can
use from google cloud platform but let's
understand what is google cloud platform
and what are some of the services
even the services which are not listed
here can be found in your console from
google cloud so what is google cloud
platform gcp
it is a set of cloud computing services
provided by google that runs on the same
infrastructure as i mentioned that
google uses for its end user products
like youtube gmail and even google
search the various set of services
offered by google cloud platform are so
you have services which are specific to
computing requirements and again in
computing you have
various different options available you
have machines which are compute
optimized machines which are memory
optimized machines which are storage
optimized and also we have certain
machines such as pre-emtiff which
basically means that you could get a
machine
to work on at a far
lesser price than any other machine but
when we talk about preemptive these are
the machines which can be requested on
demand and they can be taken back by
google at any time you have networking
related services
which can be very useful when you are
setting up your applications or your
services across globe you also have
different services which are specific to
machine learning and organizations which
would be interested in working on
machine learning or artificial
intelligence would be really interested
in using these services there are also
innovative solutions to work on big data
and big data related technologies
now when we talk about google cloud
platform domains so we can break down
these services into specifics such as
you have compute now the compute service
allows for computing and hosting
the cloud
now when you talk about computing here
there are different services
such as app engine you have compute
engine you have kubernetes you have
cloud functions and cloud run when you
talk about storage and database so the
storage and database service allows
application to store media files backups
or other file like objects
now various services under this are as
follows you have cloud storage cloud sql
cloud big table for unstructured data
you have cloud spanner cloud data store
persistent disks and cloud memory store
when we talk about networking the
networking service allows us to load
balance traffic across resources now as
i mentioned earlier resources could be
your different resources which you would
be using from a cloud platform such as
your devices your instances memory
optimized or cpu optimized instances or
other resources creating dns records and
much more so various services under this
are vbc that stands for virtual private
cloud you have cloud load balancing
cloud armor cloud cdn you have cloud
interconnect dns and network service
tiers when we talk about the big data
service this allows us to process and
query big data in cloud now various
services under these are as follows you
have bigquery cloud cloud data proc
cloud composer cloud data lab cloud data
prep cloud pub sub which is publish and
subscribing system you have cloud data
studio now you also have the developer
tools and developer tools service
includes tools related to
development of an application now
various services under these are as
follows that is you have cloud sdk
software development kit you have
deployment manager cloud source
repositories and cloud test lab when we
talk about identity and security which
is one of the primary concerns for any
organization or any user who would be
interested in using a cloud platform
google cloud really has taken care of
this
so when you talk about identity and
security domain this deals with security
services now various services here
are cloud identity you have identity and
access management that is cloud iam you
have identity aware proxies you have
cloud data loss prevention api
security key enforcement key management
service and many more
you also have cloud services which are
related to internet of things so very
much would be used by organizations who
would be working on iot devices or the
data generated by these devices so
various services here
are cloud iot core you have edge tpu and
cloud iot also when we talk about cloud
ai that is artificial intelligence this
comprises of services related to machine
learning and much more so you have cloud
auto ml cloud tpu cloud machine learning
engine job discovery
dialog flow enterprise natural language
cloud text to speech and much more
if you would be interested in services
related to api platform then there are
different services under this category
or this domain so you have maps platform
you have apg api platform monetization
developer portal analytics that is api
analytics apg sense cloud endpoints and
service infrastructure
so these are some of the listing of
services under each cloud platform
domain
now let's look at
ferrero use case and let's also
understand what was done here so ferro
is one of the famous chocolate and ranks
third among worldwide chocolate and
confectionary producers it was found in
1946 in italy i'm sure you would have
seen the ferrero chocolates when you
would have gone out to buy some
chocolates
so the challenges here was that federal
as we know is sold in every supermarket
and is known for its quality once the
business grew some issues arose right
and that's what happens when the
business grows
you have issues popping up which could
be related to
the volume of data the speed with which
the data is getting generated the
variety of data and also looking at your
platforms with support different dynamic
applications or your scalability
requirements performance requirements
and so on
so it needed data storage processing and
analysis system for a wide customer
database
there was a huge gap between the company
and the people who bought its goods
because the company relied on data given
sales outlets now that's one of the
challenge
pharaoh wanted to create a digital
ecosystem where there was a point of
contact with its customers and also a
foundation for an innovative data-driven
marketing strategy what was the solution
here so one of the service of
cloud platforms or google cloud platform
is bigquery and this was an answer to
ferraro's challenges since it was
capable of hyper fast and efficient data
analysis as a solution
now as i mentioned bigquery is a data
warehouse which allows you to store
structured data now this could directly
be used as a service where you could
store in any amount of data and you
would not be paying for storage so there
are different pricing models
and
for data
up to one terabytes you would not be
charged anything
and if you would be accessing the data
that is reading the data or processing
the data from bigquery that's where the
pricing model kicks in
now using google cloud's bigquery
business analysts of federal were able
to store and analyze massive data sets
in a very reliable fast and affordable
manner
consumer behavior and sales pattern data
reports were easy to build and automate
and the analysis also followed federer
to adopt
advertising across various marketing
channels to serve the customer needs in
a better way what was the result
they could divide their database into
real-time actionable consumer clusters
to generate more accurate user profiles
ferro was also able to personalize its
marketing strategies to match the user
needs
now google cloud platform completely
tailored the website mobile content and
advertising
and created a very cost effective media
buy strategy
now these were some basics on google
cloud now as i said you can always find
a lot of details about pricing about
services
and also all the services are accessible
in your free trial account now let me
just walk you through here so one is
you could always find details on
documentation on each of these services
so if i would click on getting started
you have quick start which basically
shows you short tutorials
you have trainings and you have also
certifications now if we click on quick
start
now that takes me to this page which
shows me
quick starts
or if you would want to understand about
different projects
if you would want to look into the
documentation of creating a linux
virtual machine or storing a file and
sharing it deploying a container docker
container image and so on so you have a
lot of quick starts here you can also
look at cloud minute
on the same page on the right side you
have docs and once you click on that it
takes you to these
links now this shows you build solutions
which shows your top use cases best
practices all the solutions it's always
good to learn from these use cases which
are available and here you have
different feature products and all the
different services
which google cloud offers now you can
click on featured products and that
basically shows you a list of these
products now here we have all the
solutions which you can look at
architecture database enterprise level
big data and analysis gaming related
internet of things and so on now if you
go down here it shows you featured
products and that shows you
some of the important products such as
compute engine which is belonging to the
compute domain you have cloud run you
have anthers which is for migration
and basically cloud
adoption
when organizations would want to move
from on-premise to cloud-based solutions
you have vision ai you have cloud
storage now that basically allows you to
store any kind of data whether that's an
object so this is acting as an object
storage you have cloud sql which is
basically a ready to use
service where you would be using mysql
postgres or any other sql server
database services you have bigquery
which is a data warehouse which
basically allows you to store your
structured data
and then you have your ai and machine
learning related products so you have
auto ml vision ai video ai text to
speech speech to text and so on
now you also have different platform
accelerators which can be used and in
any of these cases for example if i
would click on compute engine which is a
featured product from google cloud now
that shows you
basically your quick starts
using your linux machines how to guides
which tells you completely working on a
vm instance
or working on storage working on
persistent disks and so on and it shows
you the documentation here now you also
have products and pricing option which
you can see for gcp pricing and you
could straight away go to the pricing
you could be looking at solutions which
talks about infrastructure modernization
now this is something which
organizations are interested in when
they would want to move from their
on-premise solution to your google cloud
now here i can say for example i click
on infrastructure modernization you can
always find some case studies what are
the different solutions we have here
right when you talk about google cloud
so you can always click on see solutions
and you can look at vm migration or sap
cloud right by google cloud what it can
be used for vmware as a service
or hpc that is high performance
computing and about these services we
will learn in detail later
now i can go back on the same page where
i was clicking on the services so you
have quick starts you have how to guides
you have deep understanding of different
concepts
right and here
if i click on all how to guides so that
shows me what are the different ways in
which you can work with compute engine
and working with different instances
although it's quite exhaustive content
but then if you follow steadily then you
can learn a lot about google cloud
now here i can just go back so this is
just giving you some idea on the
different products which are available
from google cloud looking into different
sections finding right documentation
here right and you can always look into
each one of these in detail for each
product which google cloud offers
now
if we scroll down we could see all the
options or all the domains which we see
here right let me just go back because
we got into solutions now we have quick
starts right
and then you can basically scroll all
the way down to look at cloud sdk which
can be set up on your windows machine
like i have set it up on my windows
machine
plus when you use google console you
have a gui which i'll show you in couple
of minutes and also a cloud shell where
you can use your command line options to
work with google cloud platform you have
cloud console which is nothing but your
gui to access your resources now you can
also look at in-depth tutorials pricing
and you have different other options so
let's just click on pricing here and
then we have
your price list which basically gives
you details of different services what
are available
and what are the services or what are
the prices so for example if i click on
compute engine right and this shows me
the pricing aspect of compute engine
which belongs to compute domain and here
you can see you have vm instance pricing
you have networking pricing sole tenant
nodes which are specific to particular
organizations or if organizations would
want to have dedicated nodes you have
gpu based pricing right so general
processing units you have disk and image
pricing and you can click on any of the
links and you can see
pricing which also shows you your
different kind of machine types so here
you have different kind of machine types
which says n1 n2 n2d e2 you have memory
optimized machine types you have compute
optimized you have premium images
and you can basically look at all the
categories you can look at disk pricing
which involves your persistent disk
pricing for ssds or sdds what are the
kind of images what are the different
network services right and you can
always look at
your machine types you can choose a
particular region right there is the
concept of region and availability zones
here and as per region you could look at
the prices
you can also look at standard prices you
could be looking for what are the free
tier machines if i'm specifically
looking for vm instance pricing i can
click on this one and that takes me to
the vm instance pricing what is the
billing module what is the instance up
time what is the resource-based pricing
and then you can also look at different
kind of discounts such as sustained use
discounts committed use discounts
discounts for preemptable vm instances
and so on and this is how you can be
looking at pricing for all different
resources and you can choose the
resource which you are interested in and
then look for the pricing benchmarks
reservations if you would want to use
and you would want to benefit if you
would want to look at what are the
quotas and limits and so on so please
explore this link and you can find lot
of information when it comes to
technical options looking at different
google cloud products which we briefly
discussed when it comes to domains
and what each product can be used for
you can always come back to the main
page where i was showing you different
services we went into pricing straight
away right now you can always come back
to this page
on your
cloud.google.com and then you have your
solutions
which talks about different products
right and you can click on these or you
can look into technical documentation so
this talks about your different featured
solutions infrastructure solutions you
have data center migration related and
so on so i could be talking more and
more about google cloud platform it's a
ocean it's a huge chunk of different
services for different organizational
requirements so look into this link and
also what you can do is create a account
on gmail i mean you could create a free
account or you could go to
cloud.google.com
and then you could create a free account
like i have created here and i can just
click on console now that's my gui or
google cloud console which basically
allows me to work with google cloud now
there are a lot of options here by
default when you create an account now
in my case on the top it says it's a
free trial account i have 300 credit and
out of that 251 dollars is left and 237
days out of a year are left for my
account now here i can basically see the
project right and by default we can
create a project or by default there is
a project existing for any user so when
you log in it creates a particular
project and you could create a new
project and project would be to dedicate
your different services or different
resources per different project so this
is your dashboard which basically shows
your project which shows you a project
number and a project id which is always
unique now you can click on this and
this if you would want you can hide this
information you can also look into the
documentation part of it then it shows
you the different services
or a graphical information of services
which you might have used in past so you
have compute engine which shows you how
much percentage of cpu was used you can
always go to compute engine as a service
you can look at your google route
platform status and look at the google
cloud status now this is billing now
since this shows me the billing period
for april month and i can always look at
detailed charges i can look at reporting
i can look at different apis which
google offers
and
for your different kind of work you can
always go to the api overview or the api
link and enable or disable any api now
once you enable or disable any api then
you can use that so you have news
section you have documentation and you
have getting started guides which tells
you how to work or enable different apis
if you would want to deploy a pre-built
solution add dynamic logging monitoring
errors deploying a hello world app and
so on now this is your dashboard i can
click on activity and that would show me
what kind of activity i would have done
in my cloud platform i can always choose
the kind of activities
by saying activity type i can choose the
resources now it shows me that i created
some vm instances i deleted them
i updated some metadata i basically
worked on instances i changed some
firewall rules here i have then also
worked on some other services or apis so
i created some buckets which is for
object storage
and again i have been working with some
instances and creating some firewall
rules here i have granted some
permissions i am setting up a policy
right so this activity gives me a
history of what things i have done over
the past couple of months
while working on google cloud platform
now
on the top left corner you have the
hamburger menu which you can click on
this so that's your navigation menu and
when you click on this this shows you
home it takes you to the marketplace it
specifically takes you to billing you
can always look at apis and services so
here in api services i can pretty much
go to a dashboard and i can see a report
on the traffic or errors or latency
and the kind of apis which are available
so you have compute engine api
you have bigquery api bigquery data
transfer api bigquery storage cloud data
proc so these are some of the apis or
services i've used in past might be i
was evaluating a product might be i was
using a particular product so you have
whenever you would want to use a
particular service from google cloud
platform you would be enabling these
apis so here we see some apis for data
proc you have
logging monitoring you have resource
manager api you have cloud sql which
allows you to directly use mysql or
postgres you have cloud storage
right and so many apis
so if i would want to enable a
particular api which is not right now
required but then it's good to know you
can always click on this one you can
search for an api so for example if i
would say data proc right and that shows
me the cloud data proc api which manages
hadoop based clusters and jobs on google
cloud platform so i can spin up a hadoop
cluster and i can start running some
jobs on a hadoop cluster on demand and
as i am done with it i can just get rid
of it so this is an api which i would
have to enable and then for every
particular service you also have an
admin api which you would enable
now going back so coming out from this
api library i got into api and services
now there is
you can look into the library you can
look at credentials and you can also
look at
different time intervals for which you
can see the usage of your different apis
now going back to the menu you have
support
wherein you can always reach out to the
google support team if you are using a
paid version even with free trial you
can try to reach out and you will find
someone to help but it is always good
when you have a billing cycle reaching
out the customer care you have identity
access management in admin and this is
required when you are working with
different apis or services
when you would want to have relevant
access you have getting started you have
security related options you have anthos
which is mainly for migration now here
you can look at your different domains
such as which we discussed so you have
compute
and in compute you have different
services so you have app engine you have
compute engine kubernetes you have cloud
functions and cloud run you can look
into the storage aspect which shows you
big table which is usually and mainly
for your unstructured data
big table which is something which gave
rise to
popular nosql databases like hbase and
cassandra you have data store which can
be used you have firestore file store
storage which can be used to put in data
of any kinds you have sql for structured
data you have spanner as a service you
have memory store and you have data
transfer
now when it comes to the networking
domain you have all these services such
as vpc virtual private network network
related services for your load balancing
for using a cloud-based dns or cloud
defined network you have hybrid
connectivity network service tiers
security and intelligence
then you have other options for your
operations which can be used and here
you have different other tools which can
be used such as cloud build you have
cloud tasks containers registry
deployment manager and many more
big data specific you have the services
here so you have data proc which can be
used to spin up your clusters you have
published subscribe messaging system
such as now kafka which you might have
heard of originates its idea from here
so pub sub you have data flow you have
iot core bigquery which is a data
warehouse package or data warehousing
solution from google cloud
now then you have your artificial
intelligence related services and other
google solutions
so you can always find a huge list of
services or you can say at high level
solutions offered by google cloud
and we can use these to basically test
some of the solutions use them and work
on them so i'll give you a quick demo on
different services which can be used
here from your google cloud platform now
this is your google cloud platform and
this is your console now this also gives
you a cloud shell which can be activated
so that you can work from command line
and you can always find a lot of
documentation on that so you can also
set up your cloud shell that is sdk on
your windows machine and if you have set
it up then basically you could be doing
something like gcloud right if the cloud
has been set up so in my case
i had set up the cloud sdk and basically
i can get into that
by looking at what path i have set up so
cloud sdk and then i can be using it
from my windows machine as per my
comfort i can also activate the cloud
shell here which will basically open up
a terminal and at any point of time you
can open up this one cloud shell in a
different window it is preparing the
cloud shell where it will by default set
up your project it will set up the
metadata and now i am logged into my
google cloud account from command line
and here i can basically use gcloud
right and that basically shows you the
different options which are available
which you can be using so if you would
want to use a particular service you can
also try giving a help and that shows
you how do you manage your google cloud
platform right so you have different
options for billing
to work with your different services and
basically you could be working on google
cloud using this cloud shell from your
command line
usually for people who are learning
google cloud in the beginning it is
always good to go for console and use
your different services from here in an
easier way but as i said you can always
use the command line for example if i
would just go ahead and type gcloud
create
instances
and that will directly take me to the
cloud console documentation which shows
you different options which you can use
to work with instances so i could do a
gcloud compute instances create and then
i can give my instance name and so on
and i'll show you some examples on that
so you can be using your cloud console
right that is your cloud shell and you
can straight away start working from
command line however i would suggest
using console in the beginning and when
you are well experienced then you can
start using cloud shell to do things
from command line
and when you are fully experienced you
can always switch and certain things are
usually useful or easier when done from
command line and some are easier when
you do it from the console and you can
use any one of these options now we can
go to google cloud console now as of now
i can close this one i still have my
cloud shell open if i would want to look
into it i can click on this one and i
can straight away go to compute engine
where i would want to work on creating
some instances on google cloud platform
using the compute engine service
and then basically connecting to those
instances and basically trying out some
basic things so you can click on vm
instances
and then once this comes up i can always
create some instances now if you see
here i have some instances already
created right and i can continue working
on those i can create new instances i
can use different options while creating
instances and i'll show you that in a
demo in quick seconds
so let's have a quick demo on setting up
gcp instances now before that let's have
a quick recap so when you talk about
instance or a virtual machine it is
hosted on google's infrastructure right
and you can create your google cloud
instance using this google cloud console
that is by clicking on this and then
going to compute engine and clicking on
vm instances now you can also do that
from google cloud command line tool that
is cloud shell and you can be doing that
using compute engine api
so compute engine instances can run the
public images for linux or windows
servers
that google provides you also have
option of creating or using custom
images that you can create and import
from your existing systems you can
deploy docker containers which are
automatically launched on instance
running containers optimized os now when
you talk about instances and projects
always remember that in each instance
belongs to a google cloud console
project and a project can have one or
more instances
when you talk about instances and
storage options each instance
has a small boot persistent disk which i
will show you in further screens
that contains the os you can add more
storage space if needed and when you
talk about instances and network a
project can have up to five vpc networks
so vpc network is virtual private
networks wherein you can virtual private
cloud networks where you can have your
resources within your own subnet
and each instance belongs to one vpc
network
now instances in same network can
communicate with each other through
local area network protocol an instance
uses internet to communicate within any
machine so that could be virtual
physical or outside its own network when
you talk about instances and containers
you should remember that compute engine
instances support a declarative method
for launching your application using
containers
now you can create a vm instance or a vm
instance template
you can provide a docker image and
launch the configuration
so there are different ways in which you
can create these instances and once you
create these instances you can say for
example you are creating a linux
instance you can associate ssh keys with
your google account or your g suite
account and then manage your admin
non-admin access to the instance using
im roles if you connect to your instance
using gcloud or ssh from console which
we will see later compute engine can
generate ssh keys for you and apply that
to your google cloud or g suite account
now what we can do is we can see how we
can create your google cloud instances
from your console or from the command
line let's have a look in creating
instances using gcp console now that we
have learned on some basics of google
cloud platform what are the different
services what are different domains
basically looking at your google cloud
console or even cloud shell
let's go ahead and create some vm
instances now that's from your compute
engine service and let's try connecting
to these instances and see how this
works let's also see what are the
different options which are available
when you would want to create the
virtual machine instances here so when
you click on your drop down from the top
left and choose compute engine so it
brings you to this page so i can show
that again so you can click on compute
engine click on vm instances and that
basically brings you to this page now
here it tells you compute engine lets
you use virtual machines that run on
google's infrastructure so we can create
micro vms or large instances running
different distributions of linux or
windows using standard images that is
public images and you can also have your
own image so let's create a vm instance
by clicking on create
now that's basically helping me to
create an instance here so it shows me
the instance name i can give it
something so let me say c1
now i can add labels so what is label it
basically allows you to organize your
project add arbitrary labels as key
value pairs to your resources this so
this is basically categorizing your
labels and projects if you have multiple
projects now remember if you have your
cloud console and if you have created
your free trial account it will allow
you to do these things if not you may
have to go back to the billing section
and see if the billing is enabled which
also means that when you are creating
your google cloud account it will ask
you to key in your credit card details
but they do not charge anything or they
might charge might be one dollar or one
rupee depending on your location and
that's also refunded but that's just to
verify your card now once i've given the
name i can choose a region so i would
basically choose europe since i'm in
europe i would be clicking on europe
west 3 and here i can choose an
availability zone availability zone is
basically to make your services
or instances or any other resources
highly available
so you can choose one of the
availability zones now i would choose
save s3 now this one we can scroll down
and here it says machine configurations
you have general purpose machines you
have memory optimized machines which is
m1 series and you can always go back to
the google cloud page and see
what a particular kind of machine
specializes in so i would click on
generals purpose and in general purpose
you have different categories so you
have n1 which is powered by intel
skylake cpu platform or you have e2
which is cpu platform selected selection
based on availability so let's have n1
selected now this one shows me the
machine type and if you are using your
free tier account then you can start
with collecting a micro machine which is
one virtual cpu core you can go for a g1
small which is one virtual cpu code and
1.7 gb ram you can even go up to a
high-end machine and then you can
basically see if you are using a free
account how many of these machines you
can use if i would be selecting eight
virtual cpu cores and 32 gigabyte of
memory then it would allow me to create
at least two instances by this
configuration we will use n1 standard
which is one virtual cpu core 3.75 gb
memory now then we can also deploy a
container image to this vm instance if
you would be interested in deploying a
container image let's not get into that
right now
here it shows you the boot disk and it
shows you dbn gnu 9 linux 9 what i would
do is i can go for this distribution or
i can choose a linux distribution of my
choice so here you have public images
you have custom images you also have
snapshots if you have created backup of
your previous images
here i can choose for example ubuntu and
then i can choose a particular version
so let's go for ubuntu 18.04 you can go
for the latest one also 18.04 would be
good enough and here it tells me what is
the boot disk so you have ssds or you
have standard persistent disks now ssds
are little expensive in comparison to
your standard persistent disks or your
sdds but then ssds are faster so as of
now we can choose standard persistent
disk as it is and we can let the
gigabyte be 10 now depending on your
requirement you can increase this you
can even add disks later that's not a
problem click on select now here i have
access scopes so here i will say allow
default access you can also set access
for each api or you can give full access
to all cloud apis so that based on your
requirement you can anytime change later
also we will also say allow http traffic
and we can also choose allow https
traffic that basically allows me to
access this machine or services which
are http based accessible from this
machine now i can just click on create
however it would be good to basically
enable connectivity to this machine now
we can do that in different ways one is
when you bring up your machine it will
have an ssh access which you can log in
from the cloud platform here itself or
what you can do is you can create a
private and a public key
using some software's like putty or
putty gen so for example if you do not
have that on your machine you can
download you can just type in download
putty that takes you to the putty.org
page and here you can click on download
putty and scroll down which shows you
for your 64-bit machine which i have in
my case you can download putty.exe which
is basically your ssh and telnet client
to connect to your machines you can also
use putty gen which will be allowing you
to create a private and a public key
which i have done in my case let me show
you how so what you can do is you can go
to puttygen to begin with and here you
can click on generate now then to have
this key generated just move your cursor
on the top here in the empty space and
that creates your key you can give it a
name so for example let's give a
username i would give
hdu now i can give a password for this
one so let me give a simple password
and what i can also do is i can copy
this public key from here and for my
later usage i can just keep it in my
notepad file which i can use later and
i'll show you when
so now we can save this private key and
this will basically allow me to save my
private key i can choose desktop and i
can give it a name so let's say
new key
new key and that will be getting saved
in a dot ppk file so let's save it and
that's done so we also have our public
key and we have saved our private key
now we know that when you would want to
connect using ssh you need your private
keys to the client and public key also
has to be existing so let's take this
public key so let's do a control a i'm
going to copy this and i'm going to come
back to my google cloud console and here
you can click on security so you can
click on the security tab here
scroll down and just give your public
key once you give that it resolves and
shows you the name and this is good
enough so that i can use my ssh client
to connect to this machine i can click
on create and this will basically create
my vm instance it will take some time
and then your instance will have an
internal ip which will show up here
external ip and it will also show you
options to connect to these machines so
this is my internal ip this is my
external ib which i can use to connect
from a client i can easily connect from
the option here which says ssh and i can
say open in a browser window i can even
open this in a custom port i can look at
the gcloud command which you can give
from cloud shell or you can use another
ssh so let's first do a open in browser
window and let's see if this connects so
we can easily connect to our instance in
the ubuntu 18 instance which i just set
up here easily in couple of seconds now
this is trying to establish a connection
using your ssh keys
and when you do that it also basically
brings up this web browser so i'm
already connected it shows my username
which is my cloud account username and i
have been connected to this machine here
using ssh it did not ask me for any
password and basically now i can just
check what do i have in my linux file
system right and i can anytime login as
root by doing a sudo su for example
let's try installing a package and i can
say apt-get install vim
or app get installed wget
or apt-get install
open ssh and all these packages are
already existing so not an issue now i
can start using this instance i can just
look at the disk what is available okay
now we gave around 10 gigabyte out of
which we see 8.3 gigabyte here
for the dev sda1 and then 1.8 gigabyte
available and you can continue using
this machine this was the easiest way of
connecting to a vm instance using ssh
now what we can also do is i can just
leave this and i will now try to connect
using an external ssh client right and
here you can copy the public ip so when
you want to connect to an instance you
will have to get the public ip also
remember that if you select and stop
this machine which will stop your
billing counter and if you start it
again the internal ip will remain same
but the external ip is the one which
will change
i can obviously select this machine
anytime and i can do a cleanup and i can
delete it
i can do a start of the machine if it is
stopped and i can even import the
virtual machine to be used later so
there are different options which you
can always use
so this is my instance and if you would
want to look at the details click on
this one c1 and that should basically
allow you to look at the details so it
shows you what is the instance id what
is the machine type is it reservation
specific what is the cpu platform what's
the zone and all the other details
at any point of time if you would want
to edit you can always click on edit and
you can change the details as you need
now you can also look at the equivalent
rest command to basically use the rest
api to connect to this instance for now
i have copied the public ip and i would
want to connect it using putty so let's
go in here and let's give it the host
name so i can give ubuntu i can give my
ip address so that's in my session now i
will click on ssh i would go into
authentication i'll click on browse and
this is where i need to choose the ppk
file so this is the one which we created
new key let's select this
and then i can come back to session i
can even save this and i can call it as
my instance one
let's save it and you can create any
number of instances so you see i have
created different instances here for my
google cloud or amazon related instances
and i can click on open it says the
service host key is not cached in the
registry that's fine just click on yes
and basically it says
no authentication method supported now
this could be because we have not
enabled your ssh access so let's look at
that so now let's see if we were trying
to connect using putty what was the
issue here so if i go back to my
putty select my instance load it it says
port 22 i am giving the username which
is window or sorry that's the wrong
username we gave and that might be the
reason we had set up the user ssdu so
let's save this again and now let's try
connecting to this one and it asks for
my password and you are able to connect
this right now if there was any other
issue related to network connectivity
then we could look at the rules the
inbound and outbound rules which allow
us to look into the machine now we are
connected to our machine here using hdu
user i can login as root and i can
continue working
so not only from the ssh within the
cloud console but you can use an
external ssh client and connect to your
machine so this is your ubuntu machine
and we can basically look at the space
and that basically confirms we are
connecting to the same machine which
shows 8.3 gigabytes here and 1.8
gigabytes here which we were seeing from
the ssh in the browser now let's close
this and let's go back to our instance
page now here you can always look at the
network details and this will show you
your different kind of rules that is
ingress or egress rules which basically
allows to connect to this machine from
an external network or for this machine
to connect to an external network so
here we have different firewall rules
which shows default allow http that's
your ingress rule and it tells you apply
to all it shows me what are the ip
ranges where i can specifically give the
ipf my machine it shows the protocols it
shows what are the different ports which
you have used for these services for
example rdp or ssh which shows 22 you
have icmp http and https now anytime if
you would want to make a change to these
rules that can be done by going into
your network details and say for example
you would want to work on firewall rules
so we have these
firewall rules here you can click on
this one so right now we are looking
into the network domain and we are
looking into vpc network right and this
shows me what are the different rules we
have now if i would want to create a
different firewall rule for a different
protocol
i can always click on create firewall
rule i can give it a name okay i can say
what if you would want to turn on the
firewall logs you can basically say what
is the kind of traffic so ingress
applies to incoming traffic and egress
applies to outgoing traffic and you can
then basically choose what are the ip
ranges from where you want that
connection to be coming in or to going
out you can choose a particular protocol
you can give a protocol
here with comma separated values and you
can create a firewall rule so this might
be required depending on the services
which you are running wherein you might
want to enable your access to your
machine from an external service or to
an external service so you can always go
to network details from here you can
then go into firewall rules create a
firewall rule apply that to your
instance and restart your instance so as
of now we don't need to create any
network details here because my english
or egress rules are already available
right now i can basically then have my
instance
stopped and removed so i can just do a
stop or since this is running the ideal
wave would be to do a stop i could also
do a reset now what does reset do reset
does not basically delete the machine
what it does is it does a cleanup of the
machine and it brings it to the initial
state so sometimes we might have
installed certain things on our machine
we would want to clean them up and at
that time reset can be useful
i can basically click on delete right
and i can select this and i can do a
cleanup and this is good always when you
are using a free trial account try to
use different services play around with
them and then you can clean up so that
you do not waste your free billing
credit right and you can use it for
meaningful stuff
now i have clicked on delete and within
few seconds my instance which i had
created will be deleted also to remember
is if you are creating multiple
instances
then you can connect from one machine to
other machine using ssh by using the
private file so for that we can learn in
detail later so this is just a simple
example of using your compute engine
creating your instances connecting to it
from an internal ssh or from an external
ssh client such as putty where you have
already created your private and public
keys
now i can click on the browser here and
then i can basically come out and i can
basically be looking into any particular
service so we just looked into compute
engine right you have different other
options you have instance groups you
have instance templates for example
let's click on instance templates here
and that basically shows you that you
don't have any instance template and
this basically facilitates say for
example you are working as a admin and
you would want to create an instance
template so that using that you can
describe a vm instance and then you can
basically use this template to create
different instances
you can go for sole tenant nodes you can
look for machine images you can also
look at your disks you can create a
snapshots and you can look at different
options here now let's come back here
and let's click on home and that should
take you back to your home page which
basically shows you if a particular api
which you have used recently which shows
me in the graph here
so i can go to the api's overview right
and that basically shows me if there
were any errors if i was using the
compute engine api to basically create a
vm instance and that's why we were
seeing some spike in the graph
so this is a quick demo of using your
compute engine service provided by
google cloud wherein you can create vm
instances and use those vm instances for
your application installation
for any other purpose
now that we have seen how you use your
cloud console to create an instance and
also clean it up
let's also understand how you can do
using your command line options and
let's see what it takes or what are the
different commands which you can use to
create your instances
now you can always when when you're
creating an instance you can use compute
engine which provisions resources to
start the instance so instance basically
has different states which we can see
when we are creating the instance
so you basically start the instance
instance moves into staging that is
prepared for your first boot
finally it boots up and then it moves
into running so when you look at instant
states which we will create instance in
c
it will basically have different states
such as provisioning where resources are
being allocated for instance but
instances not yet running then it goes
into staging where resources have been
acquired an instance is being prepared
for your first boot then instance
is booting up and running and if you are
stopping an instance it goes into being
stop status and it would be moved to the
terminated option you can also do a
repairing of instance and finally you
can terminate your instance or clean it
up by stopping and then deleting it
now when you say stopping and resetting
an instance you can stop the instance as
i showed earlier if you no longer need
it but if you need for future use you
can just use the reset option which will
basically wipe the contents of instance
or any application state and then
finally you can stop it and have it
terminated now when you would want to do
that using your cloud console or we have
seen the options now let's also see from
the command line tool how you can do it
so here i have the cloud shell which i
brought up from here and i basically
opened it in a new window so command
line tool enables you to easily manage
your compute engine resources in a
friendlier format than using your
compute engine api now gcloud which is
part of cloud sdk is the main command
here and then you can always auto
complete the different options here so
when you would want to create or work on
gcloud you can just type in gcloud here
and then for example i could just say
help to see different options of gcloud
which will show me different options
which you can use here now we would be
interested in compute instances so i
could also do a g cloud
compute
compute
instances and then i can basically say
create and then i can do a help now that
should show me different options which
work with gcloud compute instances
create command
which is expecting an instance name
so your google cloud sdk
which we can set up on our windows
machine or even on your linux machine is
set of tools that
helps you to manage resources and
applications
hosted on your gcp that is your google
cloud platform now here you have options
such as gcloud which i am showing you
right now you have gsutil and then you
have bq so that also can be used so you
can set up a google cloud compute if
using gcloud
now what we can do is
if we are setting up our sdk on our
windows machine then we would have to do
a gcloud init which basically
initializes your configurations for g
cloud
now here we are using a cloud shell
which was started from the console and
we don't have to basically give your
gcloud init command because it's already
initialized now you can always look at
your default zone you can look at your
region what is being used all those
things are coming from the metadata
which is being used so for example i
could be looking at the metadata for my
particular project by just doing a g
cloud and then i can say compute
and i would be interested in project
info
so i can just do a project minus info
and then i can do it describe
and then i need my project id so i can
say minus minus project
and i can get my project id from here so
you can click on this one
and that's my project id so i can click
on this one
and here i can just do a right click and
if it does not paste then you can do a
ctrl v
and then i can try to look at my project
info so this basically will give me the
metadata which is by default set and we
can always look at what are the regions
or what is the zone which has been set
so if it has been set so i'm looking at
my details it is showing you my ssh keys
and then it can be using your default
region
and your default available zones it also
shows my username and other details so
this is basically to look at the
metadata which is available now at any
point of time i can basically say add
metadata i can basically choose metadata
option and i can say my default region
should be europe which i was choosing
earlier so i can just bring up this
command again and what i can do is i can
say here where i have gcloud compute
project info where i did it described
earlier now what i could also do is i
can just say add metadata
and then i can specify what is the
metadata i would be interested in adding
i can then say google compute
default
region
and then i can basically give a region
for example europe
and then i can say west 3
and if you are not well experienced you
can always do it from console or you can
be doing it from here so i'm giving
google cloud compute google compute
default region then i can also give a
google compute default zone
and then i can pass in a value for
default zone so i can say europe
west 3
and then basically i can give an
availability zone so if
it is basically giving me some error
where i am trying to pass in these
values
so i can just give it this way and then
it basically says that if you can look
into particular help to see what is the
command which you would have to do now i
can basically do a g cloud
init here initial configuration and this
basically says that it is initializing
my
default configuration it says
reinitialize this configuration from
cloud shell
you want to create a new configuration
so if i had updated my
metadata
then basically i could just do a cloud
in it
and i could be
re-initializing my default configuration
or properties which i have passed in so
as of now i will not activate or change
the default region let's go for a simple
way in which you can create your compute
engine so for example i'll just say one
and it is re-initializing it asks me
what is the username
and let's select that it says what is
the project and let's select that
and do you want to configure a default
compute region and zone right and i will
just say yes
and basically then it shows me different
options which we have here
so there are too many options here and
then here we were interested in
europe west 3 so let's choose 21
right and then that basically allows me
to choose my region and my zone so it
also gives you some specifications so it
says your project default compute zone
has been set to europe s3 a you can
change it by running gcloud config set
and you can give a compute zone right so
i can always give these commands i can
get help information here so i can just
say gcloud config set and i can be
specifying the compute zone so i can say
compute slash zone and i can give a zone
i can say compute slash region and i can
give a region name if i would want to do
it or the easier way is like what i did
right now so you can basically do a
command gcloud in it and then basically
it allows you to change your
configuration or set
default things here you cannot all the
times you can say gcloud config unset
to basically remove a compute zone or a
compute region now there are different
ways so if you were working on a linux
machine you could always
use an export command something like
this so you could do export compute
sorry cloud
sdk
and then you can say compute underscore
zone
and then give your zone name or compute
underscore region and give your region
or you could add it in your bashrc file
right now that is when you have your
cloud sdk set up on your linux machine
or on windows machine and you would want
to specifically set a zone
and a region for all your compute
related resources so we don't need to do
that the default settings are already
given here right and what we can do is
we can start by quickly looking into
gcloud compute instances options so i
can say gcloud
compute instances
and then i can just do a list at any
point of time if you would need help you
can just do a gcloud compute and then
say minus minus help or i could just do
a gcloud compute and that shows me
different options which i have here from
which i use instances
i can always type instances and again
hit enter and it shows me different
options what you would want to do so i
can initially just type list which
should show me what are the list
or what are the instances available and
as of now we don't have any instances i
can always do a list and then i can
specify minus minus format and then try
to get the information in a json format
or ml or minus minus format text
so you can always do a list you can do a
filter so there are different options
with your list and you can you can try
doing a help here and that basically
shows you what are the options
so for example if i do a help and it
shows me with list what are the things
you can do so you can give a name
you can give a regular expression you
can say in particular zone you can use a
minus filter so there are different
commands which are available and you can
always find all those options here as i
showed you earlier so now
what we would be interested in is
basically going for your compute
instances i can always do a ssh and i
can create an instance
i can add and remove metadata right for
my instances
by giving a particular zone
by giving a particular region and if you
would want to do that now here what we
can do is we can basically create an
instance by just giving a name to that
particular instance and we can then go
back to our console and see what has it
done so i can say
here create so that's an option let's
see what does the create do so it says
okay you are giving a create option but
you would have to give a name so let's
say
let's call it e1 and that will be the
name of my instance and this one is an
easy command from your cloud shell which
basically creates an instance you see
the zone which has been set it is the
standard machine type it is not
preemptable it has an internal ip and it
has an external ip
now i have created an instance and here
i can just go back and then i can just
do a refresh on this page and that
already shows me
the instance which i have created and
then you can use the same method to
connect to it using an ssh so i have an
instance created from my cloud shell
and what i can do is i can basically
look into instances and see what are the
different options with instance so if we
did a create
right you have an option delete we did a
create you have an option delete you can
be then deleting the instance from the
command line or you can use other
options so you can do a list you can do
a stop
you can start so i can basically do a
stop and let's say even let's go ahead
and do a stop commands are pretty easy
here to remember or you can always use
the help option and now i'm trying to
stop the instance and then basically i
can go ahead and delete it so this is a
simple way where i created a instance
from the command line or from the
console which i showed earlier and
similarly you can be working with other
options
so now i've created stop the instance
let's do a listing to see
if my instance shows up it shows up
right and it says the status is
terminated so you have stopped it
it's in the terminated status and now
what i can do is i can go ahead and
delete it
so it says this will be lost are you
sure you would want to continue just say
yes
and that should take care of deleting
your instance
so this is a quick demo on creating your
instance we have already seen how you
can connect to these instances using ssh
now that we have created instances let's
also see how to use google cloud's
storage
service which can be used to load data
or upload data so for this we will have
to look into your google cloud storage
options and here you can look in cloud
storage so let's go back here on the top
which shows me different services which
we have here and let's look into storage
so this one shows me your storage option
now you can click on browser and that
basically shows me your storage browser
which shows me on the top you have
options for
creating a bucket
now google cloud storage allows you to
store any kind of data here
the easiest and the simplest way would
be by using cloud console although you
can again use cloud shell and in that
you can use your gsutil command
and gsutil basically has different
options where you can be
using say for example i would want to
work on buckets so i can be using mb and
then i can use my command line option to
create buckets i can put in data there i
can browse it and i can access the data
from command line so let's create a
bucket here let's click on this let's
give it a name so let's say my
data important that's the name
now i can click on continue straight
away i can look into all of these
options if i'm interested in
so you can basically be looking at your
monthly cost estimate in the beginning
now i can click on continue or you can
say choose where to store your data and
this one shows you different options so
you have region specific
so let's also give the bucket name with
all lower case that's what is required
yeah so coming back to the location type
you can choose multi region which
basically allows high availability so
your bucket or your storage option will
be accessible across regions
you can also give dual region and high
availability and low latency across two
regions i can also say region specific
so for our use case we can just give
region specific which can keep our cost
low but in business use cases you would
be going for multi-region
now here you have location and i would
again go for say europe and let's choose
europe west 3 frankfurt
it is always a good practice that when
you create your instances when you
create your storage
or you use different services try to
have a geographical region chosen and
then you would try to put things or your
services within the particular region
within a particular zone unless you
would want to make it
accessible and available across regions
now i can then choose a default storage
class so when you say default storage
class there are different storage class
and each one is for a different use case
so you have standard which is best for
short term storage and frequently
accessed data you have near line so this
is basically best for backups and data
access less than once a month you can
also have cold lines so these are
basically like your cold storage or
freezing storage which you might have
heard generically as terms so you can
choose one of these storage classes
depending on what will be the use case
for this particular storage bucket so
let it be standard now how to control
access to objects so you can basically
say specify access to individual objects
by using object level permissions
now you can give permissions to the
bucket you can just say
uniform access to all objects in the
bucket by using only bucket level
permissions so you can choose that you
can also go into advanced settings and
here you can see different ways in which
you can have configuration setup now you
can also have a retention policy to
specify the minimum duration where that
this bucket's object must be protected
from deletion and you can set a
retention policy will not get into all
that we will just first try creating a
bucket so just click on create and that
should create your bucket wherein i have
my bucket now i can click on overview to
see the details what is the region
which region it belongs what is the
storage class anytime you can always
click on edit bucket and make some
changes here you can look at the
permissions so bucket uses fine grained
access allowing you to specify access to
individual objects
and then you can basically look at who
has access to this so in my case
editors of the project they basically
are the bucket owners
owners of project viewers of the project
right and you can basically choose what
kind of access you need so for this
you can always go into cloud storage and
then you can decide what kind of access
you would want to give whether that's a
storage admin it's an object admin
object creator object viewer and so on
you can always look at storage legacy
and for any other services depending on
what apis you have enabled right you can
always control your permissions so right
now it is storage legacy bucket reader
and that's fine and this one is bucket
owner and then might be i was using some
other services like data proc which uses
cloud storage and that's why i've given
data's proc service agent also so these
are some of the members you can remove
you can view by specific members you can
view by roles so what are the different
roles which have access to this so it
says storage legacy bucket owner there
are two owners
based on this particular project so
these are auto controlled but then you
can add or remove machines you can
save storage cost by adding a life cycle
rule to delete objects after the
duration of current retention policy so
you can add different policies
and you can basically control your
bucket now my bucket is already created
right so i can go back and then i see my
bucket is already here i can click on
this option and you can anytime edit the
bucket permissions you can edit the
labels the default storage class you can
just go ahead and delete the bucket you
can export it to cloud pub sub so
basically if you would want to have the
content from this bucket being
accessible in a message queuing system
you can go for pub sub you can process
with cloud functions and you can scan
with cloud data loss prevention so there
are different options which are
available we can always select this
bucket and delete it now i can click on
the bucket and that basically shows me
different ways in which i can upload
some data here so i can just click on
upload files and here then i can choose
some files so for example i'll go in
here
i'll go into data sets and i have
different data sets so for example let's
choose this one which is a csv file
and then i'm just uploading this to my
cloud storage right it's as simple as
this so you can drag and drop your files
or you can just upload your files
and my file is uploaded here now i can
basically edit permissions for this one
right so this is in the bucket so anyone
who has access to this bucket can
basically download this file it can they
can copy move or rename this you can
export it and you can look at the
permissions of this file so let's look
at edit permissions and it says
for this project whoever is the owner it
has access i've also given a specific
user my gmail id and i've given access
so at any point of time you can just say
add item and then you can start giving
different kind of accesses
so let's click on cancel here
now my data is already uploaded into
this particular bucket and that's a
simple usage of your cloud storage
now what we can also do is i can
basically select this and i can delete
it i can also create specific folders
and then basically
load data into it i can click on this
one i can just do a download and then i
can download it anywhere on my machine
so let's go to desktop and let's
download this file so we not only
uploaded some content in the bucket but
we also downloaded that in a different
location which will be accessible now
what i could have also done is i could
have created a folder here and i could
have specified say for example immediate
immediate data
okay and i'm clicking on this one so
that's my immediate data i can click on
this one and now
i can upload my data specifically to
this particular folder by using the same
mechanism you can just do upload file
let's choose air passengers
let's do a open and my file will be
uploaded
so you can
always choose what is the retention
expiry date for this one so as of now
there is nothing right but you can be
deleted
objects can be deleted or modified until
there is a minimum duration you can
control all of that you can basically
download it right you can copy it and
you can move it and rename it so this is
a simple example where i created a
particular bucket right now if for
example you click on this transfer so it
says cloud storage data transfer
products have moved you can now find
storage transfer service on premise data
and transfer appliance in new data
transfer section right so you can always
go back
to cloud storage you can also look at
transfer options which are mainly when
you are using your on-premise service
and you would want to upload data in a
google cloud right so this is my bucket
here now i can go to cloud console and
here what i can do is if i would be
interested in working so i can just say
gsutil
right and then we have
for example let's try a help okay and
that basically shows me my gsutil now
you can always go to quick start gsutil
tool and this is one more way wherein
basically you can do it from the command
line so working with buckets so you can
do a gsu till mb minus b and then on a
particular zone if you would be
interested in and then you can say g is
colon and given name so my awesome
bucket this is how you will create a
bucket
which will show you it is creating a
bucket
and then basically you can upload an
image or some data from internet you can
just do a wget download the file and
then you can just do a gsutil copy
command and that basically will pick up
the file from your cloud shell location
put it in your bucket
once you have done that you can always
do a copy right so here you are doing a
copy from your local machine that is
your cloud cell machine to your bucket
and you can do the reverse of that that
is you can do a copy and you can point
your bucket and the file and download it
to your desktops so you can just
download that using the command line
and you can copy the object to a folder
in the bucket so that is by creating a
particular folder and you are pushing
the file into a particular bucket you
can list the contents of a bucket using
ls and then give your bucket name so gs
colon so we can just try this one to be
simple and rest you guys can try so here
you can just do a gsutil
you can do a ls
gs colon slash
and then i need to give my bucket name
so in my case the bucket name was
my data important so let's try that so
let's say my data important and i'm
trying to list the bucket and the
content it has right and then you have a
folder and then you can look into the
folder and look into the files so this
is a simple quick option wherein you can
use your cloud shell you could be using
your google cloud sdk from your local
machine or you can be using cloud
console to create a bucket upload some
data on it download the data see if the
data is accessible and that basically
shows you the power of cloud storage
where you can easily upload any kind of
data now what we can also do is as
you're using a free account or even a
paid account unless and until you would
want to keep the bucket you can select
it and you can just go ahead and delete
it so this will basically ask you to key
in the bucket name and let's say my data
important
you need to confirm your bucket name
click on confirm and you could have done
that using gsutil and a delete command
from the command line that is from cloud
cell so we have now created a bucket we
have uploaded some data into it we saw
how you can download it or create a
folder and upload some specific data
into it and also you can do the same
thing using gsutil tools wherein you can
list your bucket create your buckets
delete it create some folders into it
and do everything from the command line
so this is in simple way you can use
your gcp where either you can spin up
your machines or you can use cloud
storage to basically use a storage or a
easy to use instance on google cloud
platform welcome to this tutorial about
google cloud platform
and here
we will learn about cloud computing
what is cloud computing
what is gcp
that is your google cloud platform
what are the benefits of google cloud
platform and what are its different
services
a little bit about google's
infrastructure a comparison of different
cloud providers
such as google offering gcp that is
google's cloud platform amazon offering
amazon web services and microsoft which
offers azure we will also learn about
domino's pizza use case and then have a
quick demo on using some of the services
on gcp
before we begin let's understand why
cloud computing
and it would be always good to learn
about cloud computing based on a use
case there are varied use cases where
organizations are adopting or
moving
their solutions or their infrastructure
into cloud or i can simply say
integrating with cloud now here is one
use case nina started a company that
relates to website development
the challenges which nina was facing
were low memory space
whenever required for processing or for
any other kind of application related
work
high traffic to website that crashed it
and also less number of servers
now with these challenges she was then
referred to concept of cloud computing
and how that could benefit and help her
in solving her issues
most of her issues were solved
when she started using cloud computing
and with cloud computing she could
increase her memory space as required
that is on demand
control the load
to the website that is basically load
balancing and handling more requests on
the website or request per minute
buying
servers at a lower price that is
scaling up or down based on the
requirement
when we talk about cloud computing
cloud computing is use of hardware and
software components which a cloud
provider offers as a service
which can be accessed over network
cloud computing is use of these
resources which could be either
dedicated resources or coming from a
pool of resources which cloud provider
offers to deliver a service to clients
users can access these different
services
applications files from any device
which can basically access internet
cloud computing allows automatic
software integration
it allows backing up and restoring of
data
it basically offers unlimited storage
memory or computation capacity
it gives access to reliable sources
which usually the cloud provider
themselves are using for their use case
and it is a cost efficient model which
helps organizations to quickly
integrate
or
basically modernize their infrastructure
cloud computing is usually used
with id or
within id space
wherein
there are five traits
if there is a requirement of resources
as the business dynamically changes or
grows
so for this cloud computing offers
on-demand self-service
so
users could be using on-demand computing
resources
or memory resources storage network and
so on provided by cloud provider and
also do a self-service
all this is possible using a simple
interface
and users can be using processing power
storage network as they need and pay as
they go so there is least or no human
intervention required
when it comes to
projects which might need scalable
network access
cloud computing offers broad network
access that is accessing resources over
network across geographical regions or
what we call as availability zones which
might be multiple sites within a
particular geographical region
cloud providers also have what we call
as a resource pooling so this basically
provides a huge pool of resources which
are shared and can be accessed by
customers at a lower cost now there
might be customers which are interested
in not sharing the resources and would
be interested in dedicated resources and
in this case cloud provider also have
sold tenant offerings which help such
customers
if an it business or any other business
needs rapid elasticity
then cloud providers also have resources
which are offered which are elastic you
can get more resources rapidly as needed
and thus you can scale up and down think
of a gaming company which would be
interested in launching a new game
and they would have predicted a certain
number of users which would get on to
the portal playing the game and what
happens if the request per minute or if
the number of users who are joining in
might increase
now in this case organization would want
an underlying solution which handles
this dynamism scales
as
needed on demand and once the demand is
done scales down
this is possible using a cloud computing
solution
cloud computing solutions also include
measured services that is pay as you go
model for the usage or for the
reservations which a user or
organization would have made
for resources offered by cloud computing
so when we talk about cloud computing
one of the question which always arises
is
why is this model so compelling why is
this so interesting for organizations or
users who would want to use one or many
services from cloud computing so first
wave of trend which brought storage
cloud computing was what we call as colo
that is co-location
i.t shops
that have been
using or
managing huge amount of data from
decades
basically wanted to build
their infrastructures to handle their
business needs
now
instead of building costlier data
centers
they would rent space or share
facilities and this was being done by
organizations even in past
thus they would free up the capital for
other use cases
now this was more of user configured
managed and maintained by them
later organizations started thinking of
virtualization
so that was again user configured but
provider managed and maintained
so components of a virtualized data
center
matched that of a physical data center
and
organizations would have virtual devices
separately managed from underlying
devices
then later came container based
architectures or basically
automated services
so within google services are
automatically provisioned and configured
letting your infrastructure scale
on demand there are various reasons why
an organization would think of
integrating with cloud or
benefiting
by using cloud and thus
instantaneously
reaping the benefits of modernizing
their infrastructure
now few famous cloud providers are here
so you have amazon which offers amazon
web services and
a huge list of services
which come in with this
you have microsoft's azure you have
oracle's cloud you have saps cloud
solutions gcp which is offered by google
salesforce and so on there are many
other small players which are also
providing different services which are
cloud-based or
organizations which are partnering with
these main cloud providers thus offering
cloud services to their customers
when we talk about why google cloud
platform there are various reasons why
someone would choose google cloud
platform
gcp has better pricing compared to its
competitors
when it comes to speed and performance
it is very fast and increases the
performance of the project
live migration of apps and there are
huge number of solutions which i will
show you further in further screens
which help an organization to adopt to a
cloud platform an integrated with cloud
platform or even completely migrate into
a cloud platform
none of google's competitors provide
live migration of apps
when we talk about big data ai machine
learning kind of solutions gcp provides
a lot of innovative solutions in
comparison to other cloud providers such
as aws azure and so on
so what is google cloud platform it has
a set of cloud computing services
provided by google that runs on the same
infrastructure that google uses
to and for its end user products like
youtube gmail and so on
let's learn about benefits of google
cloud platform
such as high productivity
working from anywhere
quick collaboration high security
fewer data stored on vulnerable devices
reliable resources which can be used
across organization across geographical
regions
across countries
very flexible which allows organizations
to scale up and down
as the demand rises or as the demand
declines
and cost effective solutions for various
use cases these are some of the benefits
and
if we look into different services which
google cloud platform offers we could
look into detailed benefits which each
service offers in a different use case
which basically helps organizations
working in different domains handling
different kind of small mid or larger
businesses and with different business
goals
when we talk about google cloud platform
services here is a list of services or i
could say high level domains or
categories of services
so you have compute related services you
have storage and database you have
networking big data
developer tools identity and security
management
internet of things cloud ai management
tools and also data transfer solutions
when we talk about google's
infrastructure
google has one of the most powerful
infrastructure in the world
the infrastructure is available in two
levels the physical and the abstract
layers
you have physical infrastructure and
then you have the abstract
infrastructure
physical infrastructure consists of data
centers
extensive development of high efficiency
back-end data centers
you have a very strong backbone network
which is used by google itself and also
offered
as services to customers via gcp
platform services so
you have global messed redundant
backbone network
points of presence
when we talk about google it has 110
plus edge points of presence in more
than 200 countries and when we talk
about edge caching
edge caching platform at periphery of
their network
so this is what defines the physical
infrastructure of google now there is
much more to it rather than just these
four points when we talk about abstract
infrastructure that is divided in global
regions and zones
when we talk about
zone a zone is roughly equivalent to a
data center
and a single point of failure so you
could have your compute engine
which is within a zone or you could say
compute engine is a zonal resource
you have regions which are geographical
areas which contain multiple zones
so you could have a region for u.s
central or
europe central europe west and so on and
within a region you would have one or
multiple zones and zones basically would
allow high availability of resources
so you have cloud load balancer is an
example which is regional resource then
you have global resources and they are
available and shared across the planet
so you have various global resources
such as network
which could be even your ip addresses
and so on
now let's do a quick comparison of aws
west as your wes
gcp and let's look at what each cloud
provider offers later we will also look
into different services
in detail when it comes to google cloud
platform
what each service does
what you can benefit from which service
should you use in what case we will
learn about those in later slides
if i compare
your different cloud providers
when we talk about amazon
and its
cloud offerings that is amazon web
services or aws as we will know it
amazon web services has 69 availability
zones within 22 geographical locations
and soon it will have 12 more in future
so this number keeps growing based on
the spread of the services which a
particular cloud provider offers
here we are talking about availability
zone specific information when we talk
about microsoft's azure it has 54
regions worldwide and is available in
140 countries across the globe
when we talk about google cloud gold
cloud platform is available in 200 plus
countries across the globe
when we talk about virtual servers
amazon's ec2 that is elastic compute
cloud it is a web service which
basically helps to resize your compute
capacity where you can run your
application programs on a virtual
machine so using ec2 service you could
launch virtual instances that could have
any distribution of linux windows you
could have different specifications when
it comes to ram or cpu course or disk
you could also decide on
what kind of storage a particular
instance should use
whether the storage should be local to
the instance or whether that should be a
elastic file system or even an object
storage
when it comes to azure or microsoft's
offering as your virtual machine
that is
infrastructure as a service gives a user
the ability to
deploy and manage a virtual environment
inside a virtual network on the cloud
and this virtual network on the cloud
would be managed by cloud provider
google cloud or the offerings from
google cloud platform that is gcp vm
instances enables users to build deploy
and manage virtual machines in order to
run different kind of workloads on the
cloud now when we talk about compute
engine here it would be good to discuss
a little bit more about compute engine
and what are the different options which
google cloud offers so when you talk
about your compute engine
you have
scalable high performance virtual
machines
compute engine delivers configurable
virtual machines which run in google's
data center with access to high
performance networking infrastructure
and block storage and you could select
vms for your needs that could be general
purpose or workload optimized and when
we talk about workload optimized you
have predefined machines or you have
custom machine sizes
you can integrate compute with other
google cloud services such as ai or ml
and
go for your data analytics
you have when we talk about your gcp vm
instances just to expand on that you
have general purpose
instances which we call as n2
which provide a balance between price
and performance and they are well suited
for most workloads including line of
business applications web servers and
databases
google cloud also offers compute
optimized instances
which we call as c2 instances
which offer consistent high-end virtual
cpu performance
which are good for aaa gaming
eda
hpc and other applications
now when we talk about compute optimize
your general purpose how would we leave
memory optimized instances those are m2
machines which google offers so these
offer highest amount of memory these vms
are well suited for in-memory databases
such as sap hana real-time analytics and
in-memory caches
so if i would summarize this when we
talk about
different instances aws
also offers different kind of instances
which are memory or compute
or
disk optimized you have general purpose
and each
category of machines has a different
pricing model you can always go to an
aws website look for the pricing models
and that will give you an idea of
on-demand instances or dedicated
instances reserved instances and so on
similarly if you talk about google cloud
google cloud also has instances with
various options
which become the key features of why
customers would choose google cloud
platform such as live migration for vms
so compute engine
within your gcp can live migrate between
host systems and when i say live migrate
it basically means without rebooting
which keeps your application running
even when the underlying host systems
require maintenance you also have
preemptable
virtual machines wherein you can run bad
jobs and fault tolerant workloads on
pre-emptible vms to reduce your virtual
cpu and memory cost by up to 80 percent
while getting the same performance so
these are your preemptive or preemptable
virtual machines the only demand is
these can give you a really cost
efficient
resource usage however can be taken off
the shelf anytime and that's why we call
them preemptable virtual machines you
also have sole tenant nodes which are
physical compute engine servers
dedicated explicitly or exclusively for
users use case
and
when we talk about sold tenant nodes
these are usually good when you are
dealing with or when you are working
with your applications which we call as
bring your own license applications so
sole tenant nodes give you access to
same machine types and virtual machine
config options as regular compute
instances
so there are different options which
google cloud offers when it comes to
these instances which we are talking
about and it takes care of different use
cases in comparison to other cloud
providers which are also offering these
services such as you can have predefined
machine types you can have custom
machine types preemptable vms as i said
live migration of vms
you can use persistent disks which could
give you durable high performance block
storage you have local ssds you also
have gpu accelerators which can be added
to accelerate computational
intensive workloads such as machine
learning simulation medical analysis and
so on and you have features such as
global load balancing which makes google
cloud a unique choice
when we talk about platform as a service
amazon has
platform as a service offering which we
call as elastic bean stock
among one of its services it's an
orchestration service for deploying
applications and helping in maintaining
these applications
azure cloud service
provides a platform to write the user
application code without worrying about
the hardware resources
google app engine is a service used by
developers for building and hosting
applications on google's data centers
when we talk about server-less computing
so amazon's aws lambda is a serverless
compute service it is used to execute
backend code and scales automatically
when required when we talk about azure
you have something called as functions
which allow users
to build applications using server-less
symbol functions with a programming
language of their choice
when we talk about google cloud
gcp has cloud functions which is easiest
way to run your code in the cloud and it
is highly available and fault tolerant
so in these days when we are talking
about microservices architecture which
organizations are preferring when we are
talking about organizations which can
scale which can dynamically
change their underlying architecture
organizations would be interested in
server less computing where they do not
have to have a infrastructure set up
planned in advance before going for
their use case and this is where
monolithic applications
are really not a preferred choice
a lot of organizations are decomposing
their applications into microservices
based on
business capability or decomposing based
on sub domains we can learn about
microservices architecture later but
just to know that serverless computing
which
basically helps any organization if for
example if you have a web application
that receives
non-linear traffic and you cannot keep
an eye on your server always
it would be good to have someone to auto
scale your application serverless is
basically a computing model where cloud
service provider is responsible for
managing the piece of code without the
developer having to bother about
infrastructure setup
management maintenance and so on
now when we talk about applications
being serverless or benefiting from
serverless computing
one of the key things would be zero
administration so deploying application
without any provisioning and management
auto scaling capability that is let the
service provider worry about
scaling the application up and down
you have paper use model which any
customer would want to benefit from that
is pay only for the resources that you
have used or that you are continuing to
use
right shorten the time between
idea implementation and employment and
this is something which any organization
would want that
you would want
a faster
bring to the market solution timeline in
comparison to getting entangled with
deployment management and maintenance of
your underlying infrastructure when your
applications are facing a high demand
so when we talk about serverless
it is a function as a service
because each part of your application is
divided as functions and can be hosted
over multiple service providers
you have serverless apps which are
usually divided as separate units or
functions based on functionalities or
domains and so on so serverless
computing is getting quite popularity
these days
in comparison to the traditional
three-tier architecture
where you had a presentation layer you
had an application layer you had a
database layer now that kind of
infrastructure is not really preferred
in today's modern times when
organizations are working on different
kind of newer applications
when we talk about object storage amazon
has simple storage service that is s3 it
provides object storage which is built
for storing and recovering information
or data from anywhere over the internet
as your comes up with blob storage that
is binary large objects storage offers
large amount of storage and scalability
it stores the object in the tiers and
depending on how often the data is being
accessed now same thing applies to even
s3 which is from amazon so s3 also has
different kind of storage classes which
can be selected when a user or
organization intends to use a storage
service and when i speak about storage
classes it basically means having a
frequent access storage or a infrequent
access storage or what we call as
just an archival solution
google cloud
has cloud storage and it provides
unified object storage for live or
archive data the service is used to
store and access data on gcp
infrastructure
when it comes to advantages
amazon web services
has enterprise friendly services easy
access to resources
increase in speed and agility and that
too on demand and takes care of your
security and reliability of resources
which are offered
when it comes to azure it has better
development operations strong security
profile provides a lot of cost effective
solutions and
operation execution friendly
when we talk about google cloud one of
the key features here is better pricing
than competitors
live migration of virtual machines which
really interests lot of organizations
would want to modernize their
infrastructure without having any kind
of disruption in their existing services
improved performance redundant backups
and so on
when it comes to disadvantages
in aws you have limitations when it
comes to ec2 service well there are
different options in the kind of
machines which you can choose which you
can work on
you have a technical support fee
which is incurred network connectivity
and then also downtime which might be in
case when you're migrating azure it has
different code base for cloud and
premise
platform as a service ecosystem is not
really as efficient as infrastructure as
a service
poor management of gui and tools
integrated backup
when we talk about google cloud support
fee is quite hefty
it depends on what kind of solution or
support you would or organization would
be interested in it has a complex
pricing schema
although it has different use cases for
which
any user or any organization can benefit
from
downloading data from google cloud
services is an expensive option storage
might not be however uploading data or
downloading data would be an expensive
option
when we talk about domino's pizza use
case now while we were discussing about
these features i would really want to
spend more time in
discussing each of these features or
services in detail such as you have
compute engine
you have storage
you have big table you have data proc
and so on so there are huge list of
services now before we get into
your domino's pizza use case let me show
you this page on google cloud where you
can
look at different services so if you go
to cloud.google.com and if you look at
get started option under dock so here
you can find build solutions look at
different use cases learn from basics
of what is your google cloud what are
cloud basics then you can look at
different cloud products so here you
have products in different categories
such as ai and machine learning api
management compute containers data
analytics databases developer tools and
so on and you can always
click on any one of these to look into
different solutions which are being
offered what are the different use cases
what are the best practices when it
comes to migrating vms to compute engine
or operating containers or building
containers and so on you can always look
at featured products and that gives you
a quick snapshot of what are the
different products such as you have
compute engine you have cloud run
bigquery which is a data warehouse you
have cloud sql which is a managed mysql
or postgres you have cloud storage to
basically push in any kind of data there
you have security key enforcement ai and
machine learning and so on so you have
different feature products now if you
scroll down
to the lower end of this page
you can again look at
different solutions and that would be
really interesting to read and learn
from so you have infrastructure
modernization
you have application modernization you
have data management and so on so if i
look at
infrastructure modernization
you could basically look at the
solutions which google cloud offers
and what it does when it comes to
having your
infrastructure modernized or benefiting
by
integrating with cloud and having
immediate benefits of infrastructure
modernization you can look at different
use cases what they are doing
how google cloud really helps when it
comes to
migrating the workloads to a cloud
and how your different cloud solutions
such as vm migration you have sap on
google cloud vmware as a service and so
on and you could learn from these
different solutions which are offered
you can also look at application
modernization so not only infrastructure
modernization but organizations would
also be interested in re-looking at
their applications re-looking at how
these applications
could be moved from monolithic to
microservices architecture or how
applications can benefit from
modernization
and cloud computing offerings so you
have again different use cases here
which talks about different ways in
which google cloud can help how you can
modernize your applications how you can
use different solutions which google
cloud is offering now when you talk
about cloud computing services you can
always go into
cloud.google.com
if you have created a free account then
you can just log in and every user by
default gets a 300 free credit
so wherein they can try out different
products where they can use different
services so here if i click on console
where i'm already logged in with my
gmail account or my google cloud account
wherein i have
300 free credit out of which some is
being used you have a google cloud
console and here from the hamburger menu
you can click and you can look at
different services within different
domains so you have compute domain which
has different services such as app you
have compute engine and that basically
allows you to use your
vm instances which we were talking about
previous slides different instance
groups create your templates use soul
tenant nodes
create snapshots or backup of your data
use different zones you can go for
kubernetes which is containerized based
engine you have cloud functions
you have cloud run
and then you have storage related
different options such as big table you
have data store firestore file store
storage and so on and for each of these
services you can read about from the
google's documentation or anyways i will
be explaining that later
you can also look at networking related
operation related and other tools which
are offered by google cloud so these are
huge list of services which google cloud
platform offers in different ways for
different use cases
now let's look at this domino's pizza
use case
and see what it helps us learn about so
you can always access this page by going
to this
link which talks about customers and
then which shows you different use cases
so domino's increasing monthly revenue
by six percent with google analytics
premium google tag manager and google
bigquery
so this is
basically when
domino's started using gcp and what was
the result of that
now let's look further into this
so we all know
that domino is most popular pizza
delivery
chain operating across the globe but how
is that possible let's take a look so
the challenges were they wanted to
integrate marketing measurement across
various devices
connecting crm and digital data to
create a clear view of customer behavior
to make cross-channel marketing
performance analysis easy and efficient
now for these challenges which domino's
was facing the solution was using google
analytics premium
google tag manager and bigquery which
were used to integrate digital data
sources and crm data
reporting was made easier and more
efficient by implementing google
analytics premium because it had the
ability to access a single google
analytics account
to evaluate web and app performance
by using the new google tag manager
implementation
dominus were able to act fast
they were able to connect crm data with
digital analytics which basically
provided domino with greater visibility
on customer behavior
what was the result there was an
immediate six percent increase in
monthly revenue
eighty percent of costs and ad serving
and operations were saved
increases
agility with streamlined tag management
they obtained easy access to powerful
reporting and customized dashboards now
that was just one simple use case before
we go on to hands-on we can also talk a
little bit
back
about these services which google cloud
offers
as we discussed and some of these
services which can really make you think
why not google cloud platform so when we
talk about your different cloud platform
services let's learn about some of these
services in brief in what each service
is what it does and how it can help us
in handling our use cases or working
with different
products so let's learn briefly about
different services which google cloud
platform offers now one of the domains
is compute and then let's look at the
compute services which gcp offers now
here i can log into the console and this
hamburger menu on the top left corner i
can click on this one and go into the
compute engine section so this is the
compute domain which has app engine
kubernetes engine cloud functions and
cloud run so these are your different
services which are offered within the
compute domain and here we can get into
compute engine by clicking on this one
and then basically going to vm instances
so before we see how we can use this
compute engine let's understand about
some of the features of compute engine
which basically offers scalable high
performance virtual machines which are
configurable and which runs in google's
data center with access to high
performance networking infrastructure
and block storage so from here you can
select vm for your needs for your
general purpose
or workload optimized predefined or
custom machines now here you can
integrate compute with other google
cloud services such as ai ml and other
data analytics services you have
different machines which are offered
here such as general purpose which
provide a balance between price and
performance which are well suited for
most workloads including line of
business applications web services and
databases you also have compute
optimized machines which offer
consistent high end virtual cpu core
performance and which are mainly good
for gaming eda high process computing
and other such applications apart from
general purpose compute optimized you
also have memory optimized machines
which offer highest amount of memory and
these vms are basically well suited for
in-memory databases such as sap hana
real-time analytics and in-memory cache
now we can see these options here you
can click on vm instances while you are
logged in into your google cloud console
here you can even create an instance
template which can be used to spin up
instances for example if i click on new
vm instance from a template there are
some templates which i have already
created for my usage now here i can
basically use one of these templates or
what i can do is i can go back i can go
into instance templates and this
basically allows me to create a template
so you can click on create instance
template which basically allows you to
create templates which can be used to
spin up different instances we can give
a name to the template for example we
can say template
instance
now here i can choose machine
configurations and this is where you
have different options so you have
general purpose as i mentioned which
provide a balance between price and
performance you have memory optimized
which are large memory machine types for
memory intensive workloads you also have
compute optimized which basically give
you high performance machine types for
compute intensive workloads so you can
choose any machine configuration which
is available here based on your
requirements now if you click on general
purpose that has different options here
so you look into the series where you
have n1 series you have e2 which are cpu
platform selection based on availability
you have n2 and n2d so let's just have
n1 selected now you also have here which
talks about machine types and here we
can choose the configuration which we
are interested in depending on the
applications which will run within the
machines we can choose a machine so by
default it shows one virtual cpu core
and 3.5 gigabyte of memory or ram you
could choose a higher end machine so as
of now i'll just say n1 standard now
that basically allows me to choose these
machines so there are different features
which your compute offers such as you
have live migration for vms you have
preemptable virtual machines you have
sold tenant nodes and all those options
can be seen here now in this machine for
my boot disk i can select a distribution
which i would be interested in for
example i could be going for public
images and i can choose for example
ubuntu and then i can choose a version
so it shows me 16.04
and you also have latest versions such
as ubuntu 20. you can choose one of
these and here it asks you to choose the
boot disk type so that could be standard
persistent disk which is hdds which are
low in performance and
you can say low in cost in comparison to
ssds so ssds give you better performance
but then they are little expensive than
using standard persistent disk we can
choose this and we can give a disk size
for example 20 gigabyte and i can click
on select before clicking on select i
can click on custom images and that
shows me if you have any other images
created in your project you could use
those you could also learn about images
by clicking on this link so we'll click
on public images we have chosen this
distribution let's do a select and now
here you have identity and api access
management so let this be default you
can say allow default access and what
you need is depending on the services we
can choose it allows http and https
traffic now we would also need some way
to connect to these machines so when you
set up an instance by default you can do
ssh into it using the google cloud
console or from cloud shell you can also
give a private and a public key so here
you have the option where you can give
all these details so when it comes to
management it tells you what would you
want to go for reservations and you can
say automatically use created
reservation you could also say no you
would not want to use a reservation you
can also set up or provide a startup
script which you would want to give
whenever your machines come up and here
you have the options of preemptability
so compute offers preemptable virtual
machines so that is mainly when you
would want to run bad jobs and fault
tolerant workloads on these machines and
you can benefit with a reduced cost for
your virtual cpu and memory by 80
so these are virtual machines which
would be lasting less than 24 hours now
by default this is off and it purely
depends on your workload what you would
want to run on these instances i could
just go ahead and select preemptable
being on that and use this feature of
compute you also have on host
maintenance which talks about what would
be happening with this compute engine
instance so when compute engine performs
periodic infrastructure maintenance it
can migrate your vm instances to other
hardware and this is one of the features
which compute engine offers which we
call as live migration for vms here your
compute engine can live migrate between
host systems that is the underlying
systems on which these vm instances are
based on without rebooting which will
keep your application running even when
host system require maintenance and here
it says migrate vm instance recommended
and let that be as it is you can also
say that if there is a maintenance
happening you can terminate the vm
instance now it also talks about
automatic restart which is on which
basically means compute engine can
automatically restart vm instances if
they are terminated from non-user
initiated reasons so these are all the
settings which are available in
management and it also tells us the
different features which we have there
is also a feature called sold tenancy
which basically means sold tenant sold
tenant nodes which can be chosen so you
can have physical compute engine servers
dedicated exclusively for your use and
this is usually good when you're talking
about bring your own license
applications so sole tenant nodes give
you access to same machine types and vm
configuration options as regular compute
instances however these might be a
little expensive we can choose this one
we can also look into networking which
basically shows the default setup which
goes for auto subnet you can also choose
a particular ip
if that is required but that would cost
more you can click on disks which talk
about what do you want to do with the
boot disk when the instance is deleted
what is the encryption mechanism you
would want to use and here finally you
have security so basically as i said you
can ssh into instance using the cloud
console option and you can also provide
a public ssh key so one way of doing
that if you intend to use an external
ssh client such as putty to connect you
can create a key
so for example i can go into puttygen
and here i can say generate just move my
cursor over here and that will create a
key i can give a name to this one so
i'll say sdu will be username i'll give
a simple password which i will use to
login to this machine and then i can
save this private key which will get
saved so let's say hdu new key and this
gets saved in a dot ppk file which is
usually used when you use an external
ssh client to connect so save this one
and that saves a ppk file on your
desktop what you can also do is you can
copy this public key content from here
and this is what we would want to give
in our instance here so so that the
public key gets stored
on the instance and private key is what
we will use to connect so once i paste
it here it resolves the name to htu and
we have given the public key now in
certain cases you may want to use a
software which uses ssh to connect to
the machine and that software might not
be such as your putty so in that case
you may want a pem file or a private key
which is saved as a dot pem file so you
can also do that by going to conversions
and do a export open ssh key and then
save it so i'll say hdu new key but then
this one will be saved as a pem file on
my machine so you have ppk file which
allows you to use putty to connect to
the instance you have a pem in case a
software needs directly ssh to these
machines you also have the public key
which we have already provided in the
machine now once this is done i can
close puttygen i can go back to this
page where i'm creating an instance
template and then i can just click on
create so this has created an instance
template which i can use to spin up my
instances any number of instances using
the theme template only thing which i
would have to do is change the region
where i would want the instance to run
so now that we have created instance and
that's my this one the third option i
can go back to vm instances now i can
click on create and here i can either
create an instance from scratch by
giving all the details again or i can
just use my template so i can click on
new vm instance from a template choose
my template click on continue and once
this is done i can give my instance name
so let's say c1 i can choose the region
so i will choose frankfurt and then rest
everything is auto populated based on
the template what you have given and you
click on create now this basically
allows you to spin up an instance and
you can create any number of instances
using your template you could have
already created a new instance right
from scratch now once the instance is
created this has a public ip and a
private ip private ip will not change
unless you would want to set up a new
machine but public ip will change every
time you stop and start the machine now
this is what we need to connect to this
machine i can also do a ssh from here by
doing this in open in a browser window
let's click on this so this is an
internal way of connecting to your
instance
using ssh let's wait because it would be
transferring the ssh keys to the vm it
establishes a connection and i am
connected to my machine what we can
easily do is to confirm if we are in the
right machine we can just do a ls
to look at the file system what we can
also do is we can basically login as
root by doing a sudo su and that allows
you to get into the machine as root and
from here i can switch to hdu user which
will have a dot ssh directory in home
and that basically has authorized keys
and if we would want to see if this one
contains my public key i can just do a
cat dot ssh and then look into
authorized keys and this shows me the
public key which we had initially added
to our instance so this confirms that we
are logged into the machine which we
created now i can close this and what i
can also do is i can copy this public ip
so let's do a copy to clipboard now go
to putty and here i will say hostname
where i'll say hdu give my public key
i'll click on ssh and in ssh i'll go to
authentication now here we need to give
our ppk file so the ppk file was sdu new
key select this one come back here come
to the session give it a name for
example c1 save it and then you can just
say open and say yes and you are logged
in to your machine now once you're
logged in you can always do a minus ssh
and that shows you the file so this is
how you have just used the compute
engine to spin up an instance but we
used a template which basically allowed
me to create this instance and then i
can connect to this instance and then i
can start working on this so when we
talk about features of compute engine it
has predefined machine types as we saw
so compute engine offers
different predefined virtual machines
and this they have configurations for
every need from small general purpose
instances to large memory optimized
instances with up to 11.5 terabytes of
ram you can have fast compute instances
optimized up to 60 virtual cpu cores you
also have custom machine types so you
can create a vm that best fits your
workload and by tailoring a custom
machine type to your specific need you
can realize significant savings there
are preemptable vms which we saw there
is also a facility which allows you to
take the benefit of live migration for
vms you have durable high performance
block storage for virtual machine
instances in the form of persistent
disks where data is stored redundantly
for integrity flexibility and to resize
storage without interruption and you
could be choosing sdds or sdds for your
instances
now you also have option such as gpu
accelerators so for example if i just
click on create instance and i can look
into that so here let the instance name
be instance one and what i would be
interested in looking at this one which
says cpu platform and gpu so cpu
platform configuration is permanent you
can also do add gpu so gpus can be added
to accelerate computationally intensive
workloads like machine learning
simulation medical analysis and virtual
workstation
applications so you can add and remove
gpus to a vm when your workload changes
and pay for gpu only while using so
these are some of the features which
basically compute engine offers and we
already know that google bills in second
level increments so we only pay for the
compute time now there are different
savings which are possible so you have
commitment savings which basically means
you can save up to 57 percent without
upfront cost per instance type login
you have container support so you can
basically run manage an orchestrate
docker containers or compute engine
instances so here when we are setting up
our instances there is an option which
basically allows you to use or deploy
docker images now that can be done you
can also benefit from sustained use
savings that is sustained use discounts
which are automatic discounts for
running compute engine resources for
significant portion of the billing month
you can create a reservation for vm
instance in a specific zone which is
basically seen under your management
section here and you can ensure your
project has resources for future
increases in demand and if no longer
needed delete the reservation so these
are some of the features of compute
engine what we have done is we have
created compute engine using the console
now you can go back you can also do that
using cloud shell and you can click on
this one which activates cloud shell you
could also have the cloud sdk support on
setup on your machine which can be used
now i can just open this in a new window
and from here i can start giving
commands if i would be interested in
setting up an instance from my command
line so here you have different options
now to begin with you can just do a
gcloud and just hit enter and that will
show you different options which are
available which can be used so you have
g cloud compute here which shows an
option to create and manipulate compute
engine resources now i can just do a
queue to quit i can do g cloud compute
and that basically will again show me
different options which are available if
you would be interested in setting up
instances from the command line so here
i can say g cloud compute and then go
for instances
and if you do not know the commands you
can just hit enter that will show you
all the different options which we have
so here we have different options such
as list or create or start or update for
example i can just do a
list here to see what instances i have
and the instance which we just created
shows up here it says that status is
running i can just stop this instance i
can delete this instance i can even
create an instance by using a create
command here and you can just do a
create help which will show you what are
the different options you can give so it
says instance name
is what you need you can choose an
accelerator you can choose the boot disk
and various other options so i can just
say create and then i can give a name
for example c2 and once i click on this
one it says did you mean europe west 4
zone so it is asking me for the region
and the zone and i can say yes and these
settings are coming from my default
profile i can always change those by
changing the metadata so now we have
created an instance it says running if
we do a list again to see we see two
instances created one was in europe west
three one was only europius west four
both of them have internal and external
eyepiece
now you can do a
describe to look at the different
options here so g cloud basically allows
you different commands which you can use
to work with your instance to create
instances to change the metadata if you
would want to change the region if you
would want to add a startup script all
those options are possible from the
command line which we can learn in
detail in later sessions so this is your
compute engine as a service now that we
have learned about the compute domain
and g
compute services which is offered by gcp
let's also learn about
storage and databases that's again
within the storage domain and the
services which are offered by google
cloud platform now you can go back to
console and here you can click on this
one and here you can just scroll down to
see what are the different options in
storage so you have options such as big
table you have data store firestore file
store you have sql based services you
have storage which is object storage and
then you have other options which are
available so google cloud platform
offers different storage based services
out of which storage which is your
object storage is quite popular one
click on storage and that basically
shows you an option which talks about
storage
browser so this is your google cloud's
object storage
so when we talk about object storage it
is basically a storage where you could
store any kind of data and when we talk
about object storage it is a bunch of
bytes which we address
wherein every object will have a unique
key these unique keys are in the form of
url which allows you to access the
object so cloud storage is comprised of
what we call as buckets
which are used to store and hold your
storage objects the storage objects are
immutable and every change creates a new
version now you can also have control
access via iam that is identity access
management or via access control list so
there is also an option called object
versioning which basically says if it is
on every time you try to store the same
object a new version of the object would
be created otherwise newer option will
override old one as we cannot archive
the old version so let's see how we work
with this object storage so here you can
click on create bucket
now once you click on create bucket it
needs a name so let's say test bucket
and here i can just give say number one
so that says this is the name of my
bucket now i can directly click on
continue or it would be good to look at
different options which are available
here
so
when you click on choose where to store
your data so
it already gives me an option it says
the bucket name is already taken so let
me give it a unique name so let's say
test buck and let's call it
aua so that should be unique now here it
says choose where to store your data
so this one gives you location type so
you can have region specific buckets
which give you lowest latency that is
fastest response time within a single
region however it does not make your
storage highly available you can make a
dual region which is basically allowing
your bucket or storage to be accessible
across regions you can also make it
multi-region which is highest
availability offered as of now we can
choose region specific
and now it asks you to choose a location
now as
always i will choose
frankfurt
now i can click on continue and rest all
the rest let all the storage options be
default or you can click on a default
storage class now that tells you
based on your storage class there are
variant costs when it comes to storing
retrieving or doing any kind of
operations so you have a standard
option which says best for short-term
storage and frequently accessed data you
can also go for cold storage such as
near line which is best for backups and
data access less than once a month you
can go for freezing storage such as cold
line best for disaster recovery and data
accessed
less than once a quarter or you can go
for archiving where the data is accessed
less than once a year let's go for
standard as of now and now you can
choose how to control access to objects
so you have fine grained or uniform let
it be fine grained wherein you can give
additional permissions
at bucket level using iam or object
level permissions using access control
list
in advanced settings you can choose the
encryption and you can also choose a
retention policy so a retention policy
to specify the minimum duration that
this buckets objects must be protected
from deletion or modification after they
are uploaded
you can always learn about this more by
clicking here now once i have chosen all
the relevant options i can click on
create and that basically will create a
bucket by the name i have given i can
click on overview to basically see
brief details about my bucket such as
region what is the default storage class
and it also shows you the link url which
can be used to access your bucket it
also gives you the link for gsutil now
gsutil is a command which can be used in
your cloud shell to basically work with
your buckets you can click on
permissions to basically see what kind
of permissions are already in place and
you can then make changes you can
basically add members you can view by
different roles so for example here by
default it shows
other services such as data proc or your
bucket owner or bucket reader related
permissions which have been already
granted now once i have looked at my
bucket i can start using it i can drag
and drop and push in files here so as of
now there are no live objects in my
object storage that is in my bucket what
i can do is i can click on upload files
and then
i can choose a location from my machine
for example i'll go into data sets and
what i can do is i can choose
some of the files here
in any format let's choose csv or text
and just to open so this one will
basically upload my data sets here now
once i've uploaded the files i can
basically close this one i can look into
options here which says edit permissions
and edit metadata if you would want to
download it if you would want to copy
move or rename it if you would want to
export to a different service called
cloud pub sub which is publish
subscribing messaging system you can
scan the data now you can click on a
particular file and that basically shows
you the url which basically allows you
to access this file you can try copying
this you can click on download and
download this file you can even try
accessing this from public and that
basically shows you the content of this
file based on the permissions so this is
basically your object storage which is
one of the service which is offered what
you can also do is you can create
folders and within folders you can then
upload your data so this is your google
cloud storage option which is for your
object storage that is you can add
different items you can give different
permissions and you can use this google
cloud platforms storage service offering
now you also have other options such as
big table and we can go into that by
clicking here and click on big table so
big table is one of the service which
kickstarted nosql databases today in
market we see different nosql databases
such as cassandra hbase mongodb
couchdb
neo4j and many others so you can
basically use bigtable which was the
pioneer when it comes to your no sql
databases or not only sql databases so
the problem initially faced by google
was that of the web indexes behind
search engine were taking too long to
build so company wanted to build
database that would provide real-time
access to petabytes of data and that's
where bigtable began so big table powers
different other google services such as
gmail google maps and other services and
in 2015
it was launched as a service for
customers so when it comes to
scalability with use of bigtable you can
increase your machine count without any
downtime and you can handle admin tasks
like upgrades restarts and so on which
are basically taken care by the cloud
provider
data present in cloud bigtable is
encrypted and you can use im roles to
specify access so data written to or
from big table is through data service
layers such as managed virtual machines
hbase rest servers java services hbase
client and so on
here if i would want to use bigtable i
can click on create instance and that
basically tells me
cloud bigtable instance is a container
for your clusters now here you can give
an instance name so for example i will
say a u a and then say for example
test and let's say big table so that
will be the name of instance this will
be permanent you can choose the storage
type again you can go for lower latency
more rows red per second typically used
for real time serving use cases or you
can go for sdds which have higher
latency for random reads good
performance on scans and typically used
for batch analytics so let's go for ssds
as of now here you have cluster id which
is auto populated you can choose a
region so let's go for our favorite one
here where i can say europe west 3 i can
choose a zone here and i can then choose
how many nodes
would i want to use for my big table so
when you talk about big table service it
will have a cluster underlying which
will have various nodes which will
control your data throughput storage and
rows read per second so as of now let it
be just one node and that's enough for
our demo when we talk about performance
it basically tells you based on the
current node and storage type it tells
you how many reads can happen at
milliseconds so it says ten thousand
rows per second at six millisecond you
have rights which are ten thousand rows
per second or you have scans which are
220 megabytes per second storage which
is taken care here would be 2.5
terabytes and i can then basically click
on create now there is also some option
called replication guidance which
basically says replication for cloud
table big table copies your data across
multiple regions enabling you to isolate
workload and increase the availability
and durability of your data depending on
your use case you can have big table
which can be used to have your data
across regions
now you can click on create
with all your specifications chosen and
that's going to set up a cluster or you
can say a fully managed nosql database
which will give you low latency and
replication for high availability now
once we have a new instance you can
connect to it with the cbt command line
tool and for instructions you can click
on learn more here you can just click on
this instance id to see the details
again if you would want to look into
your big table setup so it tells me here
that we have one instance what is the
cpu utilization time how many rows were
read or written what is the throughput
and this is
auto populated based on your usage you
can click on monitoring and that
basically will give you different
widgets which will display information
for your cpu utilization what is your
hottest node depending on how many nodes
you have system errors automatic
failovers storage utilization and so on
you can click on key visualizer which
will allow you to look into your table
if you have already created some data
here and you can click on tables to see
how many tables you have added here so
that's in brief about your big tables
which is
one thing which we need to remember is
it's not good for
all use cases
so should be used for low latency access
that is fast access and good if at least
data is greater than one terabyte for
smaller amount of data the overhead is
too high so big tables performance will
suffer if you store individual elements
larger than 10 megabytes
if you want to store bigger objects such
as images video files then go for object
storage
and that would be a better option so
always remember big table is not a
relational database it's a nosql
database and when you talk about
multi-row transactions or
online transaction processing big table
is not the right choice
so it can be used for wide range of
applications especially when you talk
about your olap that is online
analytical processing so it is designed
to store key value pairs and there can
be different use cases so for example if
you are using something like cloud data
flow or cloud data proc
where you would want map reduce kind of
operations big table can act as a good
storage because it has very high
throughput and scalability and the best
thing is that it supports hbase api thus
allowing easy integration with apache
hadoop and spark clusters which you can
bring up using one more service which
google cloud platform offers which is
called cloud data proc
so bigtable is good for real-time
analytics
it's commonly seen in financial services
iot and others and if you are thinking
of
running interactive sql then
bigtable would not be the right choice
but the other choice would be bigquery
you should also remember that this
has a cluster running and you would be
charged if this cluster kept on running
so you have to be very careful in your
free account when you're using such
services now we have clicked on this one
so i can select this one and basically i
can look at the permissions i can look
at the labels i can look at inherited
permissions here i can also
click on my instance
which we created and either you can edit
or you can just do a delete so as of now
we will just delete this which needs you
to given that name so we'll say aua test
bt
and then click on delete so whenever
you're trying out different services the
first approach should be setting up
these different services seeing how they
work basically trying connecting to them
and once you are satisfied with the
initial test then you can plan your
actions and come back and use the
service for a longer duration now that's
your big table which is one of the
offerings we can go back into storage
and here you have other options which
are available so for example we were in
big table you also have an option such
as cloud data store now that's one more
service which is offered by google cloud
platform when it comes to storage domain
so google added software on top of
bigtable which supports more than simple
key value pairs
when you talk about secondary indexes
instead of just having one primary index
when you talk about asset properties for
reliable transactions such as sql query
like language so these
features or these services were added to
or on top of your bigtable which gave
birth to a new service which was
released as cloud data store so this is
where you have cloud data store and you
can
select a client cloud firestore mode so
you can go for a native mode enable all
cloud firestores features with offline
support or you can go for clouds data
store system on top of clouds firestore
so these are different options here and
here we look at the api or scalability
engine support how many rights it
supports and so on you can choose one of
these and then you can choose where to
store your data so for example if i
click on this one then it choose asks me
to choose a location so it says the
location of your database affect its
cost availability and durability choose
a regional location lower right latency
lower cost or multi-region location here
i can basically choose for example
europe
and then i can go ahead and create a
database
so it says initializing cloud firestore
in data store mode services in eu3 this
usually takes a few minutes you will be
redirect to your database once it is
ready so if we compare the pricing
structure between cloud data store and
cloud bigtable always remember cloud
data store you pay for monthly storage
which is also in the case of big table
however here you are paying for monthly
storage for reads and writes
but in case of big table you are paying
for cluster when it is running so cloud
data store is a good option for small
data
infrequent access and it acts cheaper
when you talk about large amount of data
or big data and frequent access then you
are talking about cloud big table so big
table is cheaper when you talk about
larger amount of data so here it says
since your database is empty you can
still switch to cloud firestore in
native mode to get more features you
could do that you could learn you could
say query by gql
as of now we don't have any data here
let's look at the dashboard which says
since your database is empty you can
still switch to cloud firestore in
native mode to get more features so this
is your cloud data store and it has many
features
which help you to work with your data
however some
features or important features of rdbmss
were still missing and
that's where google created
yet another big table based service
called cloud spanner now we can continue
working on cloud data store which
basically gives you one option to work
with your data
you can create an entity
here by clicking on create entity and
that basically gives you
options such as default name space you
can give a kind you can give numeric id
and you can start adding properties but
to learn more about data store we will
learn about this in further session so
as of now i'm going to click on cancel
i'm going to go back to my data store
and this basically
let's go to data store option
or i can go into admin here which
basically says if you have entities you
can import or export them so let's go
back and let's again look into storage
options so as of now we were in data
store
let's click on this one
so as i mentioned your cloud data store
which basically gives you some
additional features on top of your big
table but what google also did was it
realized that there was a need for rdbms
feature support that is there were a lot
of features now here we have created a
data store and it says your data base is
ready to go just add data you can create
entities start putting in data and then
you can go ahead and query this so if
you would want to learn more about your
data store you can just click on this
one and that takes you to the complete
documentation of native mode and data
store mode what is firestore in native
mode what is in data store mode what are
pricing and locations how you choose a
database mode what are the feature
comparisons what you can do what you are
allowed to do here what programming
languages can be used different regions
pricing and so on as of now we'll click
on this one and let's look at one
advanced service which google cloud came
up with when it comes to your additional
features of rdbms so google created yet
another big table based service called
cloud spanner now that you might not see
here but if you scroll down you should
be able to see your cloud spanner
in the options here
or did we miss it on the top so let's
again look here yeah so it is here and
you can click on spanner so cloud
spanner was released in 2017 it
basically supports relational schema so
it offers strong consistency for all
queries which can be sql based you can
have multi-region deployment
now when it comes to massive scalability
requirement and strong consistency cloud
spanner is a good option so it says
cloud spanner is a managed mission
critical globally consistent and
scalable relational database so if you
would want to use this then you will
have to enable this api which shows you
an option here it says try this api so
it's a managed service
so it is one of the google's most
expensive database services there is
also one more database service which is
cloud sql which can be used so when we
talk about your cloud spanner it is
fully managed relational database
service it is massively distributed you
can have millions of machines across
hundreds of data centers with support
automatic sharding and synchronous
replication it gives you low latency and
schema updates without downtime making
data high availability and reliability
so we'll learn about cloud spanner
with more details later in other
sessions now we can also go back to
storage and we can look at the different
options which we have here so you have
object storage you have spanner you also
have your sql based service which is yet
another managed service offered by
cloud or google cloud i would say so
that's called cloud sql so this is
basically a service which allows you to
have fully managed relational mysql
postgres and sql server databases google
handles replication patch management
database management and other things
which are related to this managed or
fully managed database service it can
allow you to handle terabytes of storage
capacity with 40 000
iops with
huge amount of ram per instance so you
can click on create instance here and
then you can choose one of the database
which you would want to use so cloud sql
is a managed service you can choose one
of your mysql or postgres and sql server
say for example i choose mysql now that
basically tells me what is the instance
id it
sets up a password you can always change
the password you can change the region
you can choose your database version and
then you can also look at other
configuration options which talk about
machine type which will be used what is
about your backup and recovery
maintenance and all that and if you
click on create this will basically
create a fully managed sql service which
can allow you to straight away start
using mysql on cloud thus allowing you
to store your relational data when we
talk about storage options how can we
not talk about a data warehouse solution
or basically an option which allows you
to
run your queries by directly updating
data so you can
use a data warehouse service which
google cloud platform offers and that's
called bigquery so basically you can be
looking into
the
big data section here and here you have
an option called bigquery so this
basically brings ease of implementation
and speed so building your own database
house can be expensive time consuming
and difficult to scale so with bigquery
you just load data and pay only for what
you use so it when it comes to features
you have
features such as capability to process
billions of rows in seconds and if you
would want to do real time analysis of
streaming data that is also possible
here so here we have clicked on bigquery
which basically shows you the option
where you can start typing your query
and test your data access for example if
i have uploaded some data so
it shows me there are some queries which
are saved here now i can schedule your
query i can basically choose the format
of a particular query by clicking on
this more
here i have an option which says add
data so i can pin it to a particular
project i can explore public data sets i
can create a connection so if i click on
explore public data sets then it takes
me to a page from where you can get
different kind of data sets which are
already available which you can put into
your bigquery and start querying your
data by default it shows that it is
aligned to my project and i don't need
to worry about it i can look at saved
queries if i have already saved a
particular query i can look at job
history i can look at transfers
scheduled queries and reservations so
query basically
initially had its own version of sql
which was slightly different from
standard sql but in 2016 bigquery 2 was
released that supports sql 2011 standard
you can always select standard sql
now bigquery when it comes to pricing we
need to remember that the storage is
where the storage cost is very less here
approximately 0.02 cents per gb per
month
it is almost similar to near line where
you can also have low cost that is 0.01
cents per gigabyte per month there is no
charge for reading data from storage
when it comes to querying and that's
where the cost is incurred so one
terabyte per month is free and after
that it costs
few cents per gigabyte so this is mainly
for high volume customers there is a
flat rate by pricing which can be used
so when you talk about querying you can
save your query results you can create
data set to store the results now
results are put in a temp table in cache
and after you're done with that you can
delete data set and delete all the data
so when you talk about loading data into
bigquery you can get the data from cloud
storage google drive cloud data store
stack driver stack
uh driver other options you have cloud
bigtable or
other web interfaces so you can download
from url such as csv json avro you can
create data set create table and create
from source by doing a file upload
so 10 megabyte or less
files can be uploaded using web
interface as an option you can also use
command line and then you can start
working with
your bigquery
so
here you can also work with streaming
data by basically pushing in streaming
data into your bigquery which allows you
to add one record at a time now you
could use something like cloud data flow
which
allows you to use a particular pipeline
about cloud data flow we will learn
later so you can benefit from different
features of bigquery and thus use
google's offering to work on your
structured data or i would say data
which suits well in data warehouses now
these are some of the storage related
services which google cloud offers
although we will learn about using
bigquery and running
or uploading some data by creating add
data set here
by say creating connection or
using a public data set so as of now i
have this you can also access the
command line to work with this but we
will learn in detail about bigquery in
later sessions now here you can scroll
down and you also have an option within
big data space and that is your data
proc so when you talk about data proc
this is
again a managed service which allows you
to run spark or hadoop jobs so
especially if you are interested in big
data workload so for big data processing
for machine learning you can always use
cloud data proc
this uses compute engine instances under
the hood but takes care of management
of these instances so it's a it's a
layer on top to spin up clusters it's a
managed service it's cheaper pay when
the jobs are running only it's fast
because it is integrated with other
google cloud services you have open
source components pre-installed and data
proc is integrated with yarn to make
cluster management easier when you talk
about data proc you can click on create
cluster and that basically allows you to
set up your cluster by choosing a
particular region which you would want
to use for example i'll choose europeast
4. here it tells what kind of machines
you would want to use and by default it
has populated
as the machine here which is 4 cpu and
15 gigabyte now since you might be using
a free account let's not go for the high
end machine let's go for n1 standard 2
and then you can scroll down it says
what is the primary disk what is the
disk type and this one was for your
master machine that is machine which
will have the master processes running
then you have your
worker node configuration which tells
this will be let's choose a lower end
machine and we can choose how many
worker nodes you would have so it says
minimum two you can choose the ssds and
their capacity it talks about yarn cores
and yarn memory which will be allocated
and here we have
then option of clicking on create so
once you click on create this will
basically spin up a cluster wherein you
can
straight away start submitting jobs to
this you can basically go ahead once
your cluster is ready you can go into
the cluster you can submit a job you can
choose a type which is spark or any
other application which you would want
to run and then basically you can use
this fully managed service which allows
you to run your big data clusters you
can obviously control access via roles
or access control list and you can have
access
as it is at project level or based on
your data proc cluster or even at your
worker notes
so we'll learn about data proc in later
sessions so as of now you see here the
cluster is getting created it says the
cloud storage bucket which it is using
is this one now i can click on this and
open link in a new tab it still takes me
into console but now it is showing me
the bucket which is being used by your
data proc cluster this is the bucket
which is being used and it is being used
for underlying metadata which gets
stored here so you look at the cluster
related folders you can click in these
folders and then it can see what is the
script output what it is doing and so on
now i can come back here to my bucket
which will basically show me what kind
of buckets have been created so you see
data proc service automatically created
some buckets which will be holding some
data you also have some other buckets
which were created based on other
services which we used the access
control is fine grained in all cases
plus it also shows our bucket so
underlying it is using compute instances
it is basically using let's go here and
let's go to compute engine and let's
look into vm instances
so data proc which has spun up a cluster
is also using the vm instances which we
see here are running it is using the
buckets and it has made a cluster ready
to use so you can click on this cluster
and that shows me my cluster related
details if there are any jobs running
what are vm instances what kind of
configurations it has used
and you can look at different details
here you can look at the logs you can
click on jobs and that will show you if
you have
basically run a job on this ready to use
cluster so it says there is this
particular job which was run
which was a spark job you can click on
submit and this one tells you what is
the job id what is the region you would
choose for example we will again choose
for example europe quest 4 it tells what
is the job type so you can run all these
type of jobs in this cluster such as
hadoop spark pi spark hive pig presto
you can give your jar file so if you are
packaged your application is a jar you
can mention that here you can pass in
some arguments you can also say some
other jar files add some properties and
then click on submit which will run your
job on this ready to use cluster now
since we have tested it i can basically
go ahead and do a delete i don't want to
incur any cost on these managed services
which are running so there are a lot
more information about using these
services which google cloud platform
offers and we can continue learning
about these services as we explore your
google cloud console or even your
command line option now we can come out
of this one
by clicking on this menu and then we
have other options such as kubernetes
you have cloud functions you have your
networking related services monitoring
related services different kind of tools
what you have you have other big data
specific services which you can learn
about and for each of these servers
google has a very good documentation
available for example when you talk
about publish subscribe messaging system
it is a real-time managed service which
basically is a pioneer
which was used and now you have a famous
service such as kafka which is being
used for your publish subscribing or
messaging system kind of requirements
so to conclude about
google cloud platform services you can
always go to
cloud.google.com and look into the
document section now here you have list
of different featured products you also
have list of your different domains and
services which google cloud offers and
you can learn about all the different
services which are offered by google
cloud here you can click on featured
products and that basically shows you
compute engine cloud run cloud storage
you have cloud sql bigquery vision ai
you can scroll down and look at your
artificial intelligence and machine
learning related services platform and
accelerators api management
so google cloud platform offers
different services in mainly in your
compute storage and databases you have
networking related services
big data specifics
developer tools cloud ai
identity and security
iot management tools api platform and so
on so basically learn about the gcp
services which google cloud platform
offers and in detail you can play around
with different services which are
offered by creating a free account and
as i demonstrated you can use any one of
these services quick start them
basically connect to them put in your
data or use a managed service to manage
your data and benefit from google cloud
platform thus
having modernized infrastructure for
your different use cases hi guys today
we've got something very special in
store for you we're going to talk about
the best cloud computing platform
available amazon web services uh rahul i
think you said something wrong here the
best cloud computing platform is
obviously google cloud platform no it
isn't aws has more than 100 services
that span a variety of domains all right
but google cloud platform has cheaper
instances what do you have to say about
that well i guess there's only one place
we can actually discuss this a boxing
ring so guys i'm opexia and i will be
google cloud platform and i'm rahul i'll
be aws so welcome to fight night this is
aws versus gcp
the winner will be chosen on the basis
of their origin and the features they
provide their performance in the present
day and comparing them on the basis of
pricing market share and options the
things they give you for free and
instance configuration now first let's
talk about aws aws was launched in 2004
and is a cloud service platform that
helps businesses grow and scale by
providing them services in a number of
different domains these domains include
compute database storage migration
networking and so on a very important
aspect about aws is its years of
experience now aws has been in the
market a lot longer than any other cloud
service platform which means they know
how businesses work and how they can
contribute to the business growing also
aws has over 5.1 billion dollars of
revenue in the last quarter this is a
clear indication of how much faith and
trust people have in aws they occupy
more than 40 percent of the market which
is a significant chunk of the cloud
computing market they have at least 100
services that are available at the
moment which means just about every
issue that you have can be solved with
an aws service now that was great but
now can we talk about gcp i hope you
know that gcp was launched very recently
in 2011 and it is already helping
businesses significantly with the suite
of intelligent secure and flexible cloud
computing services it lets you build
deploy and scale applications websites
services on the same infrastructure as
google the intuitive user experience
that gcp provides with dashboards
wizards is way better in all the aspects
tcp has just stepped in the market and
it is already offering a modest number
of services and the number is rapidly
increasing and the cost for a cpu
instance or regional storage that gcp
provides is a whole lot cheaper and you
also get a multi-regional cloud storage
now what do you have to say on that i'm
so glad you asked let's look at present
day in fact let's look at the cloud
market share of the fourth quarter of
2017. this will tell you once and for
all that aws is the leader when it comes
to cloud computing amazon web services
contributes 47
of the market share others like
rackspace or verizon cloud contribute 36
percent microsoft azure contributes 10
the google cloud platform contributes 4
percent and ibm software contributes 3
47
of the market share is contributed by
aws you need me to convince you any more
wait wait wait all that is fine but we
only started a few years back and have
already grown so much in such a less
span of time haven't you heard the
latest news our revenue is already a
billion dollars per quarter wait for a
few more years and the world shall see
and aws makes 5.3 billion dollars per
quarter it's going to take a good long
time before you can even get close to us
yes yes we'll see now let's compare a
few things for starters let's compare
pricing for aws a compute instance of
two cpus in 8gb ram costs approximately
68 us dollars now a computer instance is
a virtual machine in which you can
specify what operating system ram or
storage you want to have for cloud
storage it costs 2.3 cents per gb per
month with aws you really want to do
that because gcp wins this hands down
let's take the same compute instance of
two cpus with 8gb ram it will cost
approximately 50 dollars per month with
gcp and as for my calculations that's a
25 annual cost reduction when compared
to aws talking about cloud storage cost
it is only 2 cents per gb per month with
gcp what else do you want me to say
let's talk about market share and
options now aws is the current market
leader when it comes to cloud computing
now as you remember we contribute at
least 47 percent of the entire market
share aws also has at least 100 services
available at the moment which is a clear
indication of how well aws understands
businesses and helps them grow yeah
that's true but you should also know
that gcp is steadily growing we have
over 60 services that are up and running
as you can see here and a lot more to
come it's only a matter of time when we
will have as many services as you do
many companies have already started
adopting gcp as a cloud service provider
now let's talk about things you get for
free with aws you get access to almost
all the services for an entire year with
usage limits now these limits include an
hourly or by the minute basis for
example with amazon ec2 you get 750
hours per month you also have limits on
the number of requests to services for
example with aws lambda you have 1
million requests per month now after
these limits across you get charged
standard rates with gcp you get access
to all cloud platform products like
firebase the google maps api and so on
you also get 300 in credit to spend over
a 12 month period on all the cloud
platform products and interestingly
after the free trial ends you won't be
charged unless you manually upgrade to a
paid account now there is also the
always free version for which you will
need an upgraded billing account here
you get to use a small instance for free
and 5gb of cloud storage any usage above
this always free usage limits will be
automatically built at standard rates
now let's talk about how you can
configure instances with aws the largest
instance that's offered is of 128 cpus
and 40 views of ram now other than the
on demand method like i mentioned before
you can also use spot instances now
these are the situations where your
application is more fault tolerant and
can handle an interruption now you pay
for the spot price which is effective at
a particular r now these part prices do
fluctuate but are adjusted over a period
of time the largest instance offered
with google cloud is 160 cpus and 3.75
tbs ram like spot instances of aws
google cloud offers short-lived compute
instances suitable for bad jobs and
fault tolerant workloads they are called
as preemptable instances so these
instances are available at eighty
percent off on on demand price hence
they reduce your compute engine costs
significantly and unlike aws these come
at a fixed price google cloud platform
is a lot more flexible when it comes to
instance configuration you simply choose
your cpu and ram combination of course
you can even create your own instance
types this way before we wrap it up
let's compare on some other things as
well telemetry it's a process of
automatically collecting periodic
measurements from remote devices for
example gps gcp is obviously better
because they have superior telemetry
tools which help in analyzing services
and providing more opportunities for
improvement when it comes to application
support aws is obviously better since
they have years of experience under
their bed aws provides the best support
that can be given to the customers
containers are better with gcp a
container is a virtual process running
in user space as kubernetes was
originally developed by google gcp has
full native support for the tools other
cloud services are just fine tuning a
way to provide kubernetes as a service
also the containers help with
abstracting applications from their
environment they originally run it the
applications can be deployed easily
regardless of their environment when it
comes to geographies aws is better since
they have a head start of a few years
aws in this span of time has been able
to cover a larger market share and
geographical locations now it's time for
the big decision so who's it going to be
yeah who is it going to be gcp or aws i
think i'm going to go for choosing the
right cloud computing platform is the
decision that's made on the basis of the
user or the organization's requirement
on that note i believe it's time for us
to wrap this video up we hope you guys
enjoyed this video and learned something
new that aws is better right no that
choosing a platform entirely depends on
you and your organization's requirement
hello everyone welcome to this session
on google cloud platform website hosting
and let's understand what google cloud
platform offers when it comes to your
web hosting requirements
here
we will learn about google cloud web
hosting
some basics of cloud computing
web hosting service providers what is
gcp and why go for it
different types of web hosting which are
possible a use case such as lush
and a quick hands-on on using gcp for
web hosting
when you talk about cloud web hosting
google cloud
has the feature of hosting a secure and
reliable websites easily
it ensures customers and sites
protection the website is a is
hosted on a fast and reliable network
you can do more work for less price with
google cloud
now when we talk about google cloud it
is always good to know some basics over
cloud computing
now when we talk about cloud computing
cloud computing is basically using
resources which are provided by your
cloud service provider such as google
cloud and cloud computing basically
means using hardware and software
components to deliver a service on a
network now here users can access
files applications from any device
that can access internet so when we talk
about
cloud computing this is basically using
services which are hosted
on the infrastructure managed by cloud
provider when we talk about resources
which can be used that may include
big data services storage options your
computing options networking options and
various other services which a cloud
provider offers
cloud computing has various different
service models such as you have platform
as a service
software as a service infrastructure as
a service
also these days we talk about containers
as a service
and these are your different computing
service models which are being offered
by cloud service providers which allow
you for automatic integration with your
existing environment or if you would
want to benefit from modernization by
using a cloud providers infrastructure
you have different services which are
offered some of them are for auto
software integration
or migration
backing up and restoring data
scaling your storage capacity that is
going for an unlimited storage capacity
and using a resource provided by cloud
service provider benefiting from
reliability cost efficiency which is
offered by a cloud provider in this case
we are talking about google cloud when
you talk about web hosting service
providers there are various web hosting
service providers you have aws
you have squarespace ibm cloud godaddy
bluehost and google cloud
so what is gcp and why go for it
when you talk about gcp or as we call it
as google cloud platform it is set of
cloud computing services provided by
google that runs on the same
infrastructure that google uses for it
end user products like youtube gmail and
much more
when you talk about gcp
there are various reasons why anyone
would choose it for their use cases now
let's look at some reasons when you talk
about pricing gcp has better pricing
compared to its competitors depending on
the services which you would use
whether that would be infrastructure as
a service such as using compute engine
instances and running your applications
on them or might be a managed service
such as data proc
or big table or your big query where you
can have your hadoop clusters running or
store huge amount of data or even build
your data warehouse wherein you can
store structured data so there are
different services with gcp offers and
pricing has been a better option in case
of google in comparison to other
competitors
when you talk about speed and
performance it's very fast and increases
the performance of your project if you
use different services offered by google
when you talk about live migration of
apps this is one of the features which
organizations usually like which none of
other competitors are offering when it
comes to live migration of apps so there
are specific features for example when
you talk about computer engine there is
a feature stating live migration wherein
your resources or your instances which
are running applications would be
migrated during say maintenance from one
underlying host to another underlying
host without affecting your
application's performance
and you can benefit from that
when you talk about big data google
cloud has various offerings in big data
space and that's one of the advantages
of gcp in comparison to other
competitors you have different services
for your big data needs such as pub sub
for publish subscribing messaging system
or going for data proc which basically
allows you to spin up your hadoop and
spark clusters to run your different
jobs and so on so when we talk about
features of google cloud platform it
offers high productivity because you are
using the resources which are based on
the same infrastructure which google
uses for its own different use cases
you can work from anywhere provided you
have internet connection and you can
connect to the cloud platform and use
different services offered via web you
can quickly collaborate with different
teams or different colleagues working on
different projects which might be
sharing or using different gcp resources
you are benefiting from high security
and different encryption and security
mechanisms with gcp offers now there are
fewer sources or you could say data
which is stored or vulnerable devices
there is high reliability flexibility or
scalability which gcp offers
and the cost effectiveness really makes
it as a good choice when you would want
to benefit from infrastructure
modernization and using a cloud platform
solution for your use case now when you
talk about different types of web
hosting
google cloud offers three types of web
hosting
you have wordpress now it is a free and
open source content management system
you might have used in past or have
heard about wordpress where a lot of
websites are being created it is a
popular web publishing platform to
easily set up blogs and websites and
thus used by organizations or even
individual users for having their blogs
or running their websites or promoting
their products
you have lamp which stands for linux
apache mysql and php
and lampstack consists of linux apache
http server mysql and php and is used to
host websites and web applications
you also have your option of building
your own website so you can develop
website or web application with your own
code directly on compute engine now
let's look at a use case and understand
what happened here when we talk about
lush so
lush was founded in 1995 it's you might
have seen this brand somewhere in the
streets it is a global cosmetics
retailer headquartered in uk it sells a
diverse range of fresh handmade products
lush had become a global brand with over
930 stores in 49 countries so the
challenges which were faced here was
traffic on boxing day caused website
crash for almost 18 hours and this is
something which had a devastating effect
on their business
the previous platform had no scalability
option what was the solution the
movement of website during the peak time
was easy due to flexibility of gcp
platform with rapid vm deployment on
google compute engine the environments
were monitored and destroyed in minutes
so the team could test and deploy at
speed by using google cloud sql plus
took complete control of its
infrastructure and optimize its systems
for effective scaling overall the
platform resulted in lower cost that led
to a bright future for lush cosmetics
now what was the result of all this
the availability during peak loads was
improved because of google compute
engines auto scaling feature the
infrastructure hosting costs were
reduced by 40 percent streamline data
center usage from 5 to 3 with google's
high quality private network really
benefited lush and it provided a
flexible architecture and scalability
for future business growth now what we
have seen here is that your google cloud
and its web hosting basically offers
users to run their websites or use a web
hosting solution that can benefit in
more than one way the simplest approach
could be seen is by
clicking and setting up a vm instance by
going to your console for example if we
go in to the google cloud platform
clicking on console
and here the easiest way i could test it
is by going to my compute engine
vm instances and here i can spin up an
instance i can click on create now in my
previous sessions i have also explained
about how you could create a template
and run an instance from that we can
also click on new vm instance let's call
it new instance
i will choose a region
for example frankfurt i will let it be
general purpose machines let this
machine be one virtual cpu core and 3.75
gigabyte ram if i'm looking for a
heavier website which might have more
users logging in and so on then i can
choose a higher configuration machine
here we have the option to choose our
distribution so for example i can choose
ubuntu and then i can choose a
distribution version so let it be 16.04
we can choose the disk size to be 20
gigabyte and we can use ssds or hdds so
as of now it is standard persistent disk
that is hdd and that should be enough
let's click on select
here i will say allow default access i
would say allow http and https
so that if i have a website content
hosted on this machine i can access it
over http now here you have management
options for your instance you have
security option which basically allows
you to provide a public key if you are
interested in using an external ssh
client to connect now i have used
puttygen and i have already created a
private key which is here i have also
converted that as a pem file and anytime
if i would want to use this key all i
need to do is click on puttygen where i
had earlier created this ppk file now i
can just do a load and i can choose the
key which i have here
and i can give the pass face click on ok
and that shows you the public key let's
copy the public key from here let's go
into our instance and i can give this
here that resolves the name so i have
the private key saved on my machine and
public key which will be pushed into the
machine i can click on create and that
should create my instance to which you
can connect using ssh from the console
itself or using a external client such
as putty which will then need the public
ip of this instance the ppk file what we
have and you can connect to this
instance what i can also do is i can
just do a simple ssh from here and that
will basically allow me to connect to
the instance
what we also need to remember is each
instance what we create in compute is
also having some default firewall rules
now i have connected to my instance i
can click on sudo su i can log in as
root and here if i would want i can
install a particular service so let's
say apache
let's say apt-get install and then i can
say apache 2 or httpd that is basically
to host your web application
so i'm installing this service
and here i can check if the service is
running by doing a service httpd
status or i can say service
apache 2 status which says it is already
running that means the apache web server
page
will be accessible from http provided my
firewall rules allow that now before we
look into this we can also for our
instance look at the firewall rules so
here you have network details now since
we created an instance by default google
has created some firewall rules which
allow default http https icmp your
default internal access rdp and ssh
access and here it says
these ingress rules which allow incoming
traffic are allowed from anywhere we can
customize that as specific ip addresses
we can also look at egress which is
basically outgoing traffic and this is
again saying my machine can connect to
the external world in different ways
using different protocols so you can
customize these firewall rules as of now
i am going to let it be default now we
connected to our instance
from the browser and we were basically
checking
how you can use this browser by clicking
on this now what i can also do is here
i'm logged into the instance my apache
server is running so the best way to
check if
the apache web server is accessible via
http
all i need is my
public ip so let's copy this let's go
here and i will say h t t p
slash slash just give your public ip and
that shows your apache to web server
page that means the apache
service has already been run
now here it tells if you would want to
host a particular page
what you will have to do is
as it says here it is based on
equivalent page on dbn from which ubuntu
apache packaging is derived if you can
read this page it means apache http
server is installed at this site is
working properly now you can replace
this file located at var www.html
index.html before continuing to operate
your http server so this is where you
can change the particular page and you
will be able to host your web site on
this particular ec2 instance what we can
do is we can check this so we can go
into the browser and we can look in var
www and that has an html folder
look into this and as of now you have a
index dot html and that basically is the
page what we are seeing now i can click
on this one and i can see i have a small
html page which is basically showing me
what we are seeing on our web server
what i can also do is for now i can test
it out and i can put in a different html
page and see how that works
so we
had basically the page here
in var
www
and then we had the html folder
and in html folder
what i had was this index file so as of
now i just moved it and i put it in a
different location so if i look in my
home hdu
index.html that shows me the complete
html page what we were seeing on our web
server
and here it shows you what this page
would display if you run it
on your http it says apache 2 ubuntu
default page
it shows it works it shows the content
and so on so for just testing i moved
this page out from this location and
what i did was i added a different page
here so that
page
if you look in html and then look in my
page dot html section i've just added
some basic details of creating html i'm
saying body i'm using marquee
and then i'm closing this with html tag
now this is a simple html page which i
created
and now what i did was once i've done
this i basically did a service apache
restart so once you do that it will take
up your new page
and once you have done that now you can
access that
by going to
your http
given your details
and then basically give your public ip
which we can get from here
and just paste it here now hit on this
so that shows me there is a mypage.html
i can click on this and that basically
shows the symbol page which i created so
as of now
this is my web page which i have created
and
this is hosted on my compute instance
now obviously we can create a more
complex website
backed up by a database use php use
mysql to store the data and then host
your website on a google cloud platform
service such as compute where your
actual code is running so we can learn
about your web hosting on compute
instances in further sessions
are you in the analytics space
have you ever wondered how data
processing in the cloud is changing the
analytic space
if the answer is yes
this is the course for you
all major corporations are moving data
infrastructure and computing to the
cloud to optimize costs to make
analyzing data seamless technology
leaders like google and amazon are
investing heavily in sas tools on the
cloud
google is a pioneer in this space
the google big cloud data and machine
learning platform provides cloud
databases managed hadoop and spark
services with tools like data flow and
data proc the platform allows for highly
scalable and reliable data processing
the data lab bigquery and cloud machine
learning features make it a great choice
for business intelligence large-scale
analytics and machine learning
its best-in-class performance and
low-cost makes google cloud popular and
sought after
technology giants like spotify and apple
have implemented the google cloud
platform at their organizations and
healthcare and consumer goods leaders
like phillips and coca-cola are
migrating to google cloud for their data
analytics needs
a google data engineer with expertise in
google cloud machine learning and
bigquery earns 102 000 per year on
average and the demand for google data
engineer certifications has never been
higher
simply learn's google cloud platform big
data and machine learning fundamentals
or cpb100 course offers a thorough
overview of the google cloud platform
covering its data processing
capabilities with various use case
studies
it's the perfect course for data
analysts business analysts and data
scientists with real world experience in
querying etl data modeling or machine
learning
i t decision makers evaluating the
google cloud platform have also found
the training very useful
the course will cover everything you
need to know about the google cloud
platform and includes
eight hours of instructor-led training
modules on big data and machine learning
with the google cloud
hi my name is randolph kale and i'm the
co-author of the google cloud platform
certification courses for google
i'm certified on the google cloud
platform an authorized google instructor
and the course advisor at simply learn
i have over 40 years experience in the
industry spanning different roles from
development
managing cloud infrastructure to product
management i've partnered with
simplylearn to ensure that you have the
best opportunity to become certified in
various google cloud platform
technologies
gain hands-on experience on the cloud
and make you job ready
before we discuss the course and the
reasons it will help you let me first
introduce you to google cloud platform
when you use the google cloud platform
you are empowered to build test and
deploy applications at google scale
the move to the cloud is happening today
there is a broad industry adoption
when i teach classes i see the pace
accelerating across all companies
forbes projects a 19
growth rate to 140 billion us dollars on
cloud services by 2019.
how can you move to the cloud how can
you make a career in this fast growing
part of the industry
your first step is establishing your
credentials in the google cloud platform
domain and you can do that by getting
certified
the google cloud platform fundamentals
course introduces you to the google
cloud platform and shows you how you can
incorporate cloud-based solutions into
your business strategies
the course is intended for solution
developers
system operation professionals and
solution architects planning to deploy
applications and create application
environments on the google cloud
platform
it is also appropriate for executives
and business decision makers evaluating
the potential of google cloud platform
to address their business needs
completing this course will give you the
skills and the confidence to take full
advantage of the google cloud platform
ecosystem
simply learn offers you extensive
training to help you understand the
platform
you get eight hours of interactive
instructor-led live online sessions
along with the course you receive a free
trial account with 300 credit toward the
use of google cloud platform for 60 days
the instructors are google authorized
trainers the content is engaging and all
the topics are very well explained
with simply learn you'll be enrolling
for the online classroom plexipass
which gives you the flexibility to
attend any of the weekday and weekend
batches according to your convenience
another thing that's impressive is the
proactive teaching assistance where
experts resolve all your course related
project related or technical questions
while pursuing the course
so if you're looking for the training
and guidance you need to have a deeper
understanding about google cloud
platform products and services this is
the best course for you
with the course material
labs and authorized instructors with
extensive experience
i don't think you'll need to go anywhere
else
take charge of your career sign up for
simply learn cp 100a training all the
best to you and with that we have come
to the end of this video on google cloud
in-depth tutorial 2022. i hope you found
it useful and entertaining please ask
away any questions you have concerning
the topics covered in this video in the
comment section below our experts will
assist you in addressing your problems
thank you for watching stay safe and
keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
you